daneben ist bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn hier vor gefahren in berlin
am axel springer haus ich möchte jetzt
mit dem gesundheitsminister über die
korona maßnahmen sprechen und darüber
was er in der vergangenen woche erlebt
hat
[Musik]
im studio herzlich willkommen herr
minister verlor vielen dank für den
besuch der minister wir wollen direkt
starten mit bildern über die in der
vergangenen woche deutschland gesprochen
hat in bergisch gladbach haben wir
erlebt wie sie ausgepfiffen wie sie
ausgebuht wurden teilweise wurden sie
dort angespuckt was macht das mit ihnen
was bewegt dass wir sehen jetzt die
bilder hier wie sie dort vor laufen und
sie wollen mit den menschen sprechen
und genau das war nicht der schweizer
fuchs wie ich verschiedentlich gelesen
habe sondern es war dass es war sehr
laut weil alle schrien das zeichen zu
sein dass uns mal reden miteinander
statt zu schreien
aber es war nicht möglich meine
erfahrung das war nicht der einzige ort
wo es auch durchaus proteste gab
was ja auch erstmal völlig okay ist
widerspruch ist eine demokratie nicht
nur erlaubt sondern erwünscht die frage
ist nur es ist widerspruch in der sache
wo wir auch versuchen einander zuzuhören
zu verstehen zu erklären ich kann auch
gut mit kritik umgehen ich finde die
gehört dazu aber es ist etwas anderes ob
man miteinander redet oder halt nur
geschrieben wird wohl nur geschrieben
wird ist kein gespräch möglich und das
ist das was wir da gesehen haben ich
kenne kam übrigens aus einer
veranstaltung vorher wo das gespräch
dann doch möglich war sind sie jemals
als politiker so ausgepfiffen ausgebuht
worden
auch ich hatte ja schon erlebt ich komme
aus einer stadt hinaus mit einem
zwischenlager kernbrennelemente
kernenergie in anderen diskussionen
gesellschaftlich auch strittigen
diskussionen wo es immer auch ein teil
gab der so gar nicht gesprächsbereit war
oder zumindest man bereit war sich eine
sekunde lang in die rolle des anderen zu
versetzen zu versuchen zu verstehen
warum der andere vielleicht eine andere
position hat weil das am ende ja alles
nicht es macht mir keine freude auch zu
merken dass das ist frust ärger gibt
also es ist ich versuche jedenfalls
immer wieder aufs neue dafür zu werben
einander zu verstehen zuzuhören nicht
einer meinung sind nicht alles konsens
sein geht nicht darum alles nachher
einer meinung aber verständnis
füreinander zu haben das ist am ende
dass eine gesellschaft zusammenhält aber
es gibt themen und das haben wir den
letzten jahren öfter
erlebt da gelingt das zumindest nicht
mit allen ich finde aber wichtig immer
wieder auch zu merken die große mehrheit
geht anders mit um
aber lassen sie uns noch einmal
zurückgehen in dieser woche was ihnen da
in diesen momenten wenn leute da gut
wenn sie spucken wenn sie sie bepöbeln
was geht da in ihrem kopf vor teilweise
habe ich gesehen wurden diese bilder
verglichen mit helmut kohl der damals in
dieser masse stand und mehr oder weniger
zurück geprügelt hat haben sie manchmal
auch den wunsch dann zurück zu brüllen
nein natürlich nicht ich habe er das ich
habe dich das bedürfnis zu versuchen zu
verstehen was was diesen frust diesen
hass auslöst weil weil ich hab zwar auf
die frage gebracht in welchem land will
man denn im moment lieber leben also ich
lasse mich auf viele diskussionen ein
und ich sag ja auch nicht dass das alles
richtig immer läuft oder dass man nicht
auch dinge hätte besser machen können
dass es nicht berechtigte kritik gibt
dass es nicht auch abwägungsfrage gibt
wir reden hier nicht über wahrheiten
sondern wir reden an vielen stellen über
das abwägen unterschiedliche interessen
und da kann es andere zugänge geben als
jetzt vielleicht den dem wir als
bundesregierung genommen haben ist alles
okay aber das alles rechtfertigt er
nicht diesen hass und diese frage stelle
ich mir wo das herkommt und was
eigentlich das modell wer auf der welt
dass die lieder schreiben lieber hätten
ich habe den eindruck die allermeisten
bürgerinnen und bürger sind eigentlich
ganz froh ich streiche eigentlich sind
ganz froh in deutschland zu sein trotz
aller härten auch im alltag gehören
diese wut sieht machen sie sich gedanken
darum ihre sicherheit bekommen sie motto
meine sicherheit neue mir nicht so viele
gedanken weil ihr auch auf uns auf uns
gegenseitig aufgepasst wird auf mich
aufgepasst wird das ist alles okay
trotzdem bleibt eben diese eine frage
warum woher kommt das was passiert da
gerade in der gesellschaft das
beschäftigt mich viel mehr als die frage
wie es mir dabei geht weil wir sehr
aufpassen müssen dass nicht was passiert
was wir auch schon in vorherigen
diskussionen bei anderen themen in den
letzten jahren gesehen haben dass da
jeder in seiner echo kammer ist seine
whatsapp gruppe hat seinen facebook
account hat und den ganzen tag nur die
meldungen sieht die ihn in seiner
eigenen oder
aber kriegen sie auch durch seine eigene
meinung werden sie bedroht
der gedanke dass wenn ich den ganzen tag
nur in der eigenen echo kammer ist die
ein bestärkt also man muss ja die kiste
darum wenig anschmeißen also wenig
nachdenken wenn man immer nur hört was
man eh schon glaubt und das ist
gefährlich finde ich für uns als
gesellschaft wenn das zu sehr
auseinander driftet und nicht in der
diskussion miteinander dann eben doch
wieder zu zusammenhalt führt das ist der
entscheidende tag werden sie bedroht
nicht mehr und nicht weniger als andere
was mir aufgefallen ist in diesen videos
die ich dort gesehen habe wird auch
erstmals wenn auch erstmals wieder
begriffe gewählt die ihm gegenüber
homophob sind ich habe da gehört das
schwule sau gerufen wurde vermuten sie
dass hinter diesen anfeindungen auch
homophobie stellt weil wir sehen halt
bei solchen situation immer dass das
kennt andere auch wie dünn manchmal die
decke ist über die wir da so gehen oder
der fairness oder wie man es nennen will
das dann in solchen situationen eben
doch auch alte stereotype vorurteile
beschimpfungen schimpfwörter wie wir sie
kennen dann wieder wieder hervorkommen
und schnell zu ihm gegriffen wird ich
finde in solchen momenten spürt man
immer wieder manchmal die decke ist über
die wir so gehen wo wir insgesamt im
glauben als gesellschaft eigentlich
schon weit gekommen zu sein was was etwa
die frage der gleichberechtigung von
schwulen lesben allen angeht sind wir
doch noch nicht so weit wenn wir diese
bilder sind wie wir denken na ja wir
sehen jedenfalls dass das alles schnell
relativ wird offensichtlich in so einer
stresssituation für einige und sie dann
schnell auch wieder zu solchen wörtern
greifen aber ich bleib dabei eins ist
mir echt wichtig damit er jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie sondern so ein
mythos entsteht die ganz große mehrheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger trägt erstens
mit die maßnahmen der bürger der
bundesregierung auch wenn da manche
persönliche härte ist und manche härte
im alltag selbst auch da wo einige
fragen haben sagen sie im großen und
ganzen ist der kurs richtig und ich
erlebe auch bei denen dies kritisch
sehen wird das ist meistens dann nicht
die schlagzeile wert
ich erlebe auch bei denen die ist
kritisch sehen in den allermeisten
situationen eine möglichkeit zum
gespräch das habe ich in den letzten
zwei drei wochen wo ich viel unterwegs
war sehr oft gespürt dass da eine ebene
ist auf der meine daten doch ein
gespräch führen kann und deswegen finde
ich darf man sich halt jetzt von diesen
situationen die wir gerade gesehen haben
dies auch ein paar anderen städten
gegeben hat aber die darf man jetzt
nicht verallgemeinern das wäre ein
falsches bild der gesellschaft erlauben
sie mir bevor wir sozusagen zu diesem
gespräch kommen doch noch eine
persönliche frage wie geht ihr ehemann
mit den beschimpfungen
ich denke das tut jetzt hier nichts zu
sagen okay dann kommen wir zu den
gesprächen
wir wollen einmal sprechen mit jemandem
der in wo wann hören was stefan schinkel
gesagt hat der bei denen bei dieser
demonstration in bergisch gladbach dabei
war und eben nicht gepfiffen hat und wir
haben ihn gefragt was er uns zu sagen
hat das seco das land die bevölkerung
otto normalverbraucher wichtig darunter
zu leiden hat und das ganze tragen und
ausbaden muss und alle anderen sich
dicke torsten masser nach hin- und
herfahren selber auch sich nicht an die
geregelten seiner gegebenen regeln
selbst nicht offen stellt für sie hier
zum beispiel mit dem aufzug wo die ganze
fraktion ohne maske ohne
abstandsregelung vollgestopften aufzug
benutzt haben jedoch nicht wenn ich was
von der bevölkerung verlangt musik hat
auch selber leben und vormachen
dort
bergisch gladbach gefragt haben es
spielt dort auf ein foto an was von
ihnen gemacht wurde in einem aufzug am
anfang der korona krise muss sagen sie
tragen eine maske
allerdings ist dieser aufzug sehr voll
und die abstandsregeln können dort nicht
eingehalten werden
wie oft vergessen sie so etwas das ist
ja auch ein neuer alltag den wir hier
alle erleben wie wie ist das für sie
naja das war eine situation die ich
hätte passieren dürfen die zu oft im
alltag immer mal wieder passiert alle
nehmen sich vor den aufzug nicht voll
werden zu lassen und auf einmal ist er
voll und der war definitiv zu voll da
gibt es nichts schönzureden
und so wie es mir geht geht es denke ich
vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern dass das
am anfang vor allem ja auch erstmal
alles sehr ungewohnt war das jedenfalls
mir manchmal auch seine unbeschwertheit
fehlte wenn ich so vor die tür trat und
uns jetzt zu wissen wo wieweit abstand
halten dann wegen gehe ich jetzt wie
weit vorbei wo es eine maske zu tragen
und wo nicht das war ja alles erst mal
neu zu erlernen für uns alle wie
begrüßen wir uns jetzt wollen wir auch
neue formen der begrüßung gefunden und
nicht mehr den handschlag
mein eindruck ist aber das ist ja auch
schon etwas älter dieses bild dass wir
das miteinander alle deutlich wir haben
besser jetzt auch im blut haben
sozusagen irgendwann mal keine fehler
jetzt mehr keine macht der mensch nie
keine herr uns einmal vielleicht oder
die bild-redaktion vielleicht aber
ansonsten keine fehler wäre unmenschlich
aber mein eindruck ist dass wir
insgesamt ist im alltag einfach gut
miteinander eingeübt haben und auch eine
hohe akzeptanz da ist aufeinander
aufzupassen das finde ich vor allem das
wichtige ich mache ja dass die dinge die
meisten dinge nicht vor allem für mich
selbst sondern um andere zu schützen
wenn einige immer sagen ich bin ein
freier mensch ich trage keine maske dann
ist meine antwort immer das ist ja nicht
nur um die eigene freiheit geht sondern
die freiheit des nächsten im bus in der
bahn im geschlossenen raum fängt halt
schon manchmal wenige zentimeter weiter
an
und es geht darum die freiheit die
gesundheit des anderen vor allem auch zu
schützen
mit einer alltags maske zum beispiel
eben in der bahn und das ist das ist
wichtig und das hat eine hohe akzeptanz
und vor allem auch mit
weil eine gute alltagstauglichkeit in
der vergangenen woche hat die
großdemonstration in berlin ganz
deutschland bewegt und wir möchten jetzt
gleich sprechen mit matthias may aus
sarstedt der bei dieser
großdemonstration dabei war und er ist
eben kein radikaler niemand der da in
irgendeiner verschwörungstheoretiker
situation unterwegs ist sondern jemand
der faktische punkte hat und da sehen
wir ihn schon matthias mehl aus sarstedt
das liegt bei hannover vielen vielen
dank dass sie sich die zeit nehmen und
ich würde direkt starten mit der frage
warum waren sie da bei der
großdemonstration in berlin dabei nehmen
sie uns mal ein bisschen mit gerne ich
bin jedenfalls ich habe eben bis hin zu
gehört und ich bin auf jeden fall nicht
wegen frust oder wut in berlin gewesen
sondern ich habe ich bin informatiker
und ich habe ihn seit beginn der korona
zeit die zahlen des lkw verfolgt und
zwar die offiziellen zahlen und ich kann
und konnte in diesen zahlen zu keiner
zeit eine epidemie von nationaler
tragweite erkennen und auch heute kann
ich keine zweite welle erkennen das
heißt ich sehe erhöhte positive tests
aber herr sparen selbst hat einmal
gesagt wenn wir die tests zahlen hoch
fahren dann werden wir falsch positiv
kriegen und wir haben aktuell glaube ich
0,79 prozent positive tests aber die
fehlerquote des pcs liegt bei ich glaube
1,4 prozent das heißt das sind fragen
wie ich hatte und die von der politik
durch die kommunikation die sie gerade
läuft nicht beantwortet werden
vielleicht sogar fehlinterpretiert
werden meiner meinung nach
und das weil diese fragen nicht
beantwortet worden bin ich nach berlin
gefahren und hab da viele viele menschen
betroffen die die gleichen fragen haben
ersparen der mel ist sogar parteikollege
von ihnen damals in die cdu eingetreten
weil die flüchtlingspolitik der
kanzlerin besonders gut fand aber darum
soll es nicht gehen
wie ist ihre antwort zum ersten mal ist
ja immer die frage das ist ein bisschen
das präventionsprogramm auch weil wir
miteinander aufeinander aufgepasst haben
ist auch relativ viel weniger passiert
also wenn manchmal ich habe jetzt den
ersten teil haben wir leider akustisch
nicht gehört von dem was sie gesagt
haben aber wenn ich es richtig
mitbekommen habe dann war es was vor
allem ja auch sozusagen die herleitung
es ist wenig relativ wenig passiert also
ist doch offensichtlich diese nationale
tragweite nicht da ich würde es eher
andersrum machen weil wir frühzeitig
hier gerade in deutschland sehr
frühzeitig reagiert haben aufeinander
aufgepasst haben maßnahmen ergriffen
haben ist so wenig passiert auch im
vergleich zu anderen ländern was die
tests seien geht das ist ein punkt der
auch wie ich finde übrigens gut
argumentiert und dargelegt gehört da bin
ich voll bei ihnen es ist so dass die
pcr test also die tests regelhaft
benutzen im moment ich hoffe dass es
bald antigen schnelltests auch gibt die
würden noch mal einen großen unterschied
machen dass die natürlich auch immer
besser werden in ihrer in ihrer
validierung auch in der frage es gibt an
den ct werte also was aussagt über die
viruslast dass man das immer besser
kalibrieren kann
nach allem was wir sehen was das
robert-koch-institut was die labore
herleiten ist allerdings die falsch
positiven rate das was sie ansprechen
also dass gesagt wird infiziert obwohl
eigentlich nicht infiziert falsch
positiv deutlich unter 1 prozent also
die tests sind einfach auch und laboren
der auswertung der tests deutlich besser
gesagt es gibt keine zweite welle
stimmen sie dem zu und da wo ich wollte
gerade sagen und da wo ein zweifel ist
beim test wird im zweifel auch noch mal
ein zweites mal dann der labortest
gemacht was die frage angeht ich habe
ich habe man mit dem begriff zweiter
welle deswegen problem weil das so
suggeriert als wir das virus mal weg
gewesen und käme wieder das virus ist da
und wird immer da bleiben wie das
masernvirus oder das
andere wären auch immer grippe wären
alle ständig da die frage ist wie gut
können wir mit ihnen umgehen wie gut
haben wir sie im griff als gesellschaft
und jeder einzelne für sich im alltag
und das am anfang war das eine große
unsicherheit ein neues virus vom
wahrscheinlich vom tier auf den menschen
übergesprungen
wo wir wenig wussten wo wir wenig
absetzen konnten und trotzdem natürlich
entscheidungen treffen mussten auch um
uns gegenseitig zu schützen
heute wird immer mehr aus dieser
unsicherheit ein risiko risiko heißt ja
wir können die dinge immer besser
abschätzen wir sind noch nicht da wo wir
mit anderen viren oder erkrankungen sind
oder anderen risiken des alltags aber
aus der totalen unsicherheit weil
totales unwissen total neu wird der tag
um tag ein immer besser bewährt bares
risiko und das ist ja was der welt
zurecht anspricht wir wissen heute im
september mehr als im märz
und ich bin sehr sehr sicher wir werden
in drei in sechs monaten noch mal mehr
wissen als wir heute im september wissen
und damit eben tag für tag auch besser
weil es neue therapien gibt los ist dann
das risiko momentan noch andere wege
neue tests gibt dann damit umgehen
können was wir sehen ist dass das risiko
dass das virus wieder eine sehr große
dynamik bekommt da ist das sehen wir in
spanien sehen wir in frankreich das
sehen wir in anderen er in spanien ist
die inzidenz mittlerweile bei über 140
pro 100000 einwohner spanien war mal mit
uns wie ganz europa auch nach sehr
harten maßnahmen in spanien armee auf
der straße passierscheine mit uns unter
10 in der inzidenz pro 100000 einwohner
jetzt sind es über 140 das heißt also da
ist eine dynamik reingekommen
die eben nicht mehr beherrschbar
geworden ist und das haben andere länder
auch gesehen das ist zum beispiel ein
hinweis darauf dass wir das noch nicht
ausreichend unter kontrolle
denn dann haben damit noch mal ganz
konkret sie waren auf der großdemo in
berlin was haben sie ganz konkret an der
politik von herrn spahn auszusetzen
ich habe eigentlich nichts an der
politik auszusetzen direkt sondern an
der kommunikation und vor allen dingen
dass die fakten nicht normal diskurs
besprochen werden dh mit
unterschiedlichen fachbereichen aber
auch mit unterschiedlichen spezialisten
in den bereichen
das heißt ich habe eben wieder gut
zugehört und ich würde zu einer anderen
bewertung kommen ich bin allerdings auch
kein fach biologie sondern einfach nur
informatik und ich kann mir nur die
statistiken angucken und ich sehe eine
grippewelle eine grippe ähnliche welle
wir haben eine sterblichkeit die
international bestätigt ist von 0,16 bis
vielleicht 0,6 prozent das ist eine
grippewelle und wir haben in den letzten
also seit bestehen der bundesrepublik
kenne ich keine maßnahmen die so
durchgeführt wurden wegen der
grippewelle und diese zahlen sind ja
bestätigt und diese zahlen einfach mal
im diskurs zu bringen also öffentlich zu
debattieren ich habe in berlin nur
menschen betroffen die genau diese
fragen haben
ich habe andere leute auch gesehen aber
ich habe viele gespräche auch mit
polizisten gehabt und viele viele
menschen haben diese fragen einfach zu
sagen
sind die maßnahmen die wir in
deutschland ich spreche jetzt erstmal
vom deutschland und sind die wirklich
nötig gewesen jemals und ich würde
tatsächlich anhand der daten des rk ii
sagen nein sie waren niemals nötig die
maßnahmen waren niemals nicht so
hinstellen
die frage ist einmal ob sie dieses
diskutiert ich meine im september zu
wissen was im märz aus ihrer sicht nicht
nötig war
die frage ist ja ob sie im märz die
gleiche einschätzung gehabt hätten
erster und zweiter mann am ende ich
meine wenn sie so so so sagen 0,16
prozent oder 0,6 prozent sterblichkeit
ist wenn sie das mal auf eine million
rechnet einwohner oder oder betroffene
ziemlicher unterschied also das klingt
nach ganz wenig ist aber für die frage
wie eine krankheit einzuschätzen ist auf
eine gesamtbevölkerung eine ziemlich
großer unterschied
deswegen bin ich ja sehr dabei himmel es
geht darum die dinge einzuordnen und
miteinander abzuwägen und daraus
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen was wir
eben sehen ist das zum beispiel da wo es
zu schwersten verläufen kommen zur
beatmungs notwendigkeiten kommt auch
insbesondere am anfang als noch auch um
klar war es gab keine medikamente
mittlerweile gibt es ja auch durchaus
therapieansätze erkenntnisse aus
obduktion aus anderen bereichen
das dann eben dort eine sehr hohe
sterblichkeit war und auch durchaus
folgeschäden da sind die diese heftig
sind und ja gleichzeitig sehen wir bei
unter 60 jährigen auch vielfach sehr
milde verläufe insbesondere bei unter 60
jahren gibt es bei älteren aber wir
schauen wo sind die risiken herrn
größten gibt es unterschiede
auch in den altersgruppen das ist ohne
zweifel so wir leben aber ja nicht
generationen getrennt man könnte ja
sagen im moment sind es vor allem eher
die jüngeren die sich infizieren das
sehen wir in allen statistiken das
durchschnittsalter ist gesunken
aber jeder 20 25 jährige hat im zweifel
großeltern
manch einer mag in der pflege arbeiten
im krankenhaus arbeiten immungeschwächte
geschwisterkind haben also wir leben ja
nicht getrennt voneinander sondern in
einer gesellschaft wo es darum geht
aufeinander aufzupassen und da bin ich
ja in der einrichtung bei herrn mel das
können wir heute besser und die dinge
besser einschätzen als im september
deswegen habe ich ja auch durchaus
gesagt mit dem wissen von heute aus den
erfahrungen der letzten monate wissen
wir im einzelhandel können wir umgehen
mit maske und abstand und maske ist das
stichwort ich möchte einmal anmelden
sagt kommen heute aber in diesen
gedanken weil daraus ja immer dann wird
hätte man im märz nicht gebraucht doch
im märz war totale unsicherheit und eine
ganz andere dynamik eine andere
situation eine andere wissens lager und
ich finde man kann die maßnahmen im märz
die damals richtig waren nicht mit dem
wissen aus september dann bewerten also
man kann das machen aber die frage ist
ob das tatsächlich die richtige
herangehensweise ist und das sehe ich
halt anders sieht es da einmal beim
thema masken masten pflicht bleiben
himmel
sie waren bei der großdemo in berlin da
waren kaum masten zu sehen ich glaube
sie sind tatsächlich auch der
überzeugung dass diese masten nicht
braucht richtig der überzeugung bin ich
tatsächlich und zwar deswegen weil ich
glaube ich mit der meinung die ich eben
geäußert habe nicht alleine bin wie
ersparen sagt sondern es gibt viel
namhafte wissenschaftler wie martin
hartl social web aktiv
die bereits im februar gesagt haben dass
diese maßnahmen nicht angebracht sind
und das ist in der wissenschaft gibt es
einen des kurses werden hypothesen
aufgestellt und diese prothesen haben
sich bis jetzt bewahrheitet die diese
wissenschaftler gesagt haben und ich
weiß wie masken pflicht an dem wort
erkennt man eigentlich schon dass das
nicht richtig sein kann in asien tragen
die leute masken und das schon seit
jahren
und zwar weil sie auf sich achten und
ich möchte meiner meinung nach noch mal
wir haben den infektionsschutzgesetz in
deutschland gehabt das ist wunderbar und
das schlägt vor nachverfolgung wenn das
nicht mehr geht schutz der älteren und
wir haben eine eigene verantwortung und
wir sind menschen die denken können und
noch mal in berlin waren genau solche
leute ich habe viele davon betroffen und
wir können in eigenverantwortung
überlegen ob wir uns die hände waschen
ob wir rausgehen und nein wenn ich eine
erkältung habe oder andere symptome dann
bleibe ich zu hause und geht ich
arbeiten dann ist ihnen schlicht
überflüssig ich muss dass ein abriss ist
die masten zu einem argument von ml was
sagen ja es gibt es gab und gibt
wissenschaftler die das auch im februar
schon anders bewertet haben es gibt
übrigens auch viele andere
wissenschaftler also deswegen ist das ja
immer jeder sucht sich so sein raus am
ende gibt es einen unterschied zwischen
ihren mail herrn backt und der
bundesregierung
wir mussten am ende entscheiden weil wir
verantwortung dafür haben was mit
menschen und menschen leben passiert das
eine ist ein buch zu schreiben
das andere ist zu wissen einer
unsicheren situation wo es ganz
unterschiedliche einschätzungen
eindrücke wissen stände gibt am ende
abzuwägen was geht in der unsicherheit
situation vor und wir haben tatsächlich
gesagt es geht vor allem auch der schutz
von leben und gesundheit vor
das ist halt schon ein unterschied ob
man eine these hat und mal guckt was
passiert ist okay oder ob man am ende
eben auch eine verantwortung hat auch
eine politische verantwortung in einer
situation zu entscheiden
und das hat jedes seine aufgabe und
seine berechtigung und aber wir hatten
eben die aufgabe in der konkreten
situation zu entscheiden zu den masken
es ist mir schon wichtig ich trage meine
maske im alltag wenn ich gerade aus
einem restaurant kommen aus
verantwortung ich trage sie nicht weil
mich jemand zwingt ich trage mich nicht
weil ich ein sklave bin wie ich lese
wäre eine maske trägt ist ein sklave ich
trage sie aus freier entscheidung und
freier verantwortung weil herr meliá sie
bringen keine 100 prozent sicherheit
aber sie bringt eben zusätzliche
sicherheit und in einer situation wo es
darum geht sich sicherheit zu erhöhen
und risiken zu vermeiden ist das doch
ein vergleichsweise mild ist mittel also
wenn ich mir so anschaue was sonst auf
der welt los ist sind wir doch in
deutschland mit dem aha regeln abstand
hygiene alltags masken die mal nervig
sind okay aber das ist doch echt ein
vergleichsweise mildes mittel im
vergleich zu all den maßnahmen die wir
eben an anderen stellen gesehen haben
und wenn wir jetzt noch eine zeitlang
herbst und einen winter lang denke ich
vor allem dann schauen wir wie es dann
ist und wie die lage dann ist aber durch
diesen herbst und winter miteinander vor
allem masken tragen und aufeinander
aufpassen wenn wir wieder mehr in
geschlossenen räumen sind dann mag das
manchmal nerven aber es schützt halt und
das finde ich es im der balance dann
doch akzeptabel ich sehe himmel sieht es
anders ich würde möchte mich ganz
herzlich
dennoch bedanken dass sie hierbei bild
live zu diesem diskurs bereit waren
unbedingt minister diskutiert haben
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
danke schön herr sparen und wir möchten
zum thema großveranstaltungen kommen das
nächste große thema das in deutschland
viel diskutiert wird zuletzt haben wir
ein großes roland kaiser konzert gesehen
und ich glaube sie sind selbst ein
bisschen kann man sagen wohin an kaiser
fan glaube ich nehme an sie waren nicht
selbst vor ort bildern die wir jetzt
hier sehen aber dennoch sieht man ja wie
das ganze offenbar funktionieren kann
haben sie da ein schlechtes bauchgefühl
wenn sie das sehen oder denken sie ja so
kann das eigentlich klar
also zuerst einmal ich mag auch gerne
konzerte und ja ich mag auch gerne
roland kaiser konzerte das ist nicht das
thema ich finde immer wichtig zu sagen
das virus ist der spielverderber nichtig
und was wir miteinander üben und jeden
tag besser lernen ist
was geht wo sind risiken vertretbar und
was sollten wir noch eine zeitlang
lassen so und wenn jetzt auf
großveranstaltungen zum beispiel wie bei
diesem konzert draußen an der waldbühne
mit abstand mit mit konzepten ja auch
wer sitzt wo wie ist der zugang dass
nicht alle gleichzeitig kommen und
gewalt und anderes mehr
wenn wir das jetzt immer besser
miteinander üben auf solchen
veranstaltungen kann das nur gut sein
also insofern spricht nichts dagegen ist
zug um zug sowie ist die verordnungen
der länder ja auch vorsehen
unterschiedlich je nach infektions lage
die ist in mecklenburg vorpommern anders
als im ruhrgebiet
zug um zug immer besser lernen auch bei
solchen veranstaltungen wie kann das
stattfinden weil wir waren gleich
veranstaltung stattfinden und sarah
connor zum beispiel nicht das verstehen
die leute nicht mehr weil erstens mal
die größenordnung unterschiedliche waren
zweites mal die zeit punkte
unterschiedliche waren und drittens mal
auch die infektions lagen und und und
die konzepte unterschiedlich waren
allerdings habe ich weder das eine noch
das andere genehmigt sondern das ist ja
nach dem infektionsschutzgesetz finde
ich es auch richtig
aufgabe der behörden vor ort
gegebenenfalls in rückkopplung mit den
jeweiligen bundesländern weil die
situation sehr unterschiedlich ist
zwischen den ländern zwischen den
regionen
und weil natürlich eine waldbühne im
zweifel noch mal ein anderes konzept ist
wer sie kennt draußen weiträumig als
möglicherweise eine geschlossene halle
das sind ja alles dinge die mit mit
beachtet werden müssen und gleichzeitig
ist es ja gut wenn wir miteinander zug
um zug lernen wie auch solche
veranstaltungen wieder stattfinden
können habe bei der gastronomie immer
gesagt und bei restaurants entscheidend
ist nicht ob sie wieder öffnen das
werden sie sondern wie
und das gilt hier eben genauso das wie
und ob ist auch die große frage
beim thema fußball und beim thema ob es
wieder zuschauer geben kann und einer
der unbedingt mit ihnen sprechen möchte
und der uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist ist
der fußballer lukas podolski herzlich
willkommen also podolski und sie haben
einen besonderen abend nachdem sie haben
ein besonderes anliegen an den minister
glaube ich ja es war schön wieder um das
spontan hallo also
vorneweg ich denke sie machen eine super
arbeit in deutschland können sich
schüler länder eine scheibe von
abschneiden
und dass man vorne weg danke und ja wie
ich wahrscheinlich sie auch und viele
deutsche fußball fans in deutschland und
natürlich meine kölner fans wo ich
ständig um anrufe bekomme fragen sich
wann können wir wieder in die stadien
dann können wir wieder in die stadien
also wir haben ja jetzt schon die ersten
stadien mit zuschauern gesehen
die letzten tage was ja eigentlich
vereinbart ist zwischen bund und ländern
das ist das thema ist ja hier das eine
ist ein konzert an einem ort an einem
abend bundesliga ist halt natürlich eine
bundesweite veranstaltungen gleichzeitig
in mehreren bundesländern wenn er alle
drei bundesligen nehmen in allen 16
bundesländern wo es dann eigentlich sinn
macht aus meiner sicht jedenfalls auch
gleiche stadt punkte zu haben das war
eigentlich vereinbart dass wir ab ende
oktober also bis ende oktober die
konzepte erarbeitet werden die zeitpläne
und dann schrittweise losgehen kann
jetzt haben wir schon einige stadien
gesehen wieder mit zuschauern
auch da ist es ja entscheiden
miteinander dass das zu üben so zu sagen
weil natürlich fußball je nachdem wie
die fans so drauf sind wir müssen halt
immer sehen es gibt natürlich
situationen und ich war selbst dich
jetzt abo dann meistens mit meinem
bruder dann er auch im stadion
der ist nämlich der begeisterte fußball
fan von beiden ich bin der hoffentlich
fc köln muss bleibt wenn hoffentlich
erste köln es ist es ist ein anderer
verein in nrw aber immerhin fast
unabhängig davon ob das glaubt maroder
leverkusen und nein keine sorge
jedenfalls weiß ich doch wie das ist
wenn man mitfiebert wenn man im zweifel
nach dem tor sich auch in den armen
liegen will und natürlich im zweifel
nachher auch feiern und zusammen hüpfen
was weiß ich will und das sozusagen
nicht zu haben erstmal sondern mit
abstand mit mit konzepten beim reingehen
beim rausgehen dass nicht alle
gleichzeitig gehen das ist das worum es
jetzt geht das zu üben wir sehen stadien
haben jetzt gesehen das wo das wann das
soweit ich das beurteilen kann gut
geklappt hat und deswegen um die frage
zu beantworten
sicher werden wir jetzt zug um zug sehen
dass die bundesliga insgesamt auch mit
zuschauern spielen wird aber trotzdem
möchte wissen wann ich kann jetzt kein
genaues datum für alle nennen weil das
tatsächlich die bundesländer diesem fall
nordrhein westfalen auch nach dem
lokalen infektionsgeschehen werden
entscheiden müssen ich ich kann auch
sehr genau warum wir da so zurückhaltend
sind
herr podolski einfach nochmal zur
erinnerung ich weiß noch sehr genau wann
ich mich entschieden habe öffentlich zu
sagen wir sollten jetzt
großveranstaltungen mal besser lassen
eine zeit das war nach dem spiel jetzt
überlege ich gerade mal mönchengladbach
sogar wenn mich nicht alles täuscht weil
es direkt in dem land kreis heinsberg
war und wir alle haben gedacht es kann
doch nicht sein dass direkt neben dem
kreis wo wir mit abstand die höchsten
infektionszahlen in ganz deutschland
damals hatten tausende auch aus dem
kreis möglicherweise dann da ins stadion
gehen eng miteinander und wir das was
wir zu karneval schon erlebt hatten ein
paar tage vorher dann möglicherweise
noch mal im fußball stadion erleben das
war ja einer der gründe warum wir dann
da auch so klar an gegangen sind dann
haben wir jetzt begonnen wieder ohne
zuschauer zu spielen ich denke das war
schon mal wichtig für die bundesliga
sowohl für die fans wie auch durchaus
für die wirtschaftliche lage der vereine
dass das wieder gehen kann und für die
spieler ist ja auch gut wenn wieder
gespielt wird
aber klar ist die stimme ist die
stimmung schöner wenn auch zuschauer
dabei sind und ich bin sicher das werden
wir jetzt eben zug um zug allerdings
wird das stadion noch nicht wieder
gleich ganz voll sein das glaube ich
kann ich sicher sagen
zug um zug daneben starten werden helfer
dort sind sie zufrieden mit der antwort
des ministers oder haben sie sich da
mehr klarheit
nein also wie gesagt viele vereine
verantwortliche und fans wollen
natürlich nicht stadien aber man muss
auf die leute in der politik das
vertrauen und die leute haben die
meinung
die leute entscheiden und am ende muss
ist jemand entscheiden und da müssen wir
auf die politik
hoffen und irgendwann während die
fenster wieder nicht stalin kommen
köppel und ich hoffe dass für die
bundesliga dann ja bald wieder ein
freund stadion sehen wann es dann so
weit wird entscheidet die politik bis
dahin müssen wir uns gedulden und vom
fernsehen zu schauen
ich glaube wieder sein da die ersten
zuschauer sehen wir haben wir auch schon
gesehen wären wir schon in den nächsten
wochen bis ende oktober sollte es ja
spätestens dann auch für alle das
gesamtkonzept gehen als dfl konzept ist
ja auch gut auf dem papier ist es super
ich sage halt nur immer papier ist das
eine auf dem platz sozusagen im stadion
ist das andere
ganz volle stadien denke ich werden wir
allerdings erst im nächsten jahr
frühestens wieder sehen das muss man
dazu sagen aber dass dieses jahr mit
zuschauern wird begonnen werden können
den ersten stadien haben wir ja gesehen
da bin ich sehr optimistisch dass das
auch flächendeckend gelingt können sie
den herrn podolski hoffnung machen dass
sie druck machen auf die
ministerpräsidenten dass jetzt alle
gemeinsam als wir haben ja vereinbart
dass bis ende oktober für alle 16
bundesländer zusammen ein konzept da ist
wie unter welchen bedingungen und
daneben auch nach der jeweiligen
infektions lage das dann dann losgehen
werden aber die erfahrung von diesem
wochenende werden sicher dazu führen
dass ist zug um zug hat ja eigentlich
schon begonnen kann jetzt auch losgehen
herzlichen dank herr podolski dass sie
sich spätabends hierbei bild live
eingeschaltet haben um den minister da
ihren flammenden appell für stadien mit
zuschauern uns zu seinen herzlichen dank
danke gerade eine große bank ich war
neben dem fußball ist natürlich die
kultur sind die barszene die
diskussionen und alle musiker und
künstler schwer betroffen von den
regelungen die sie unter anderem eben
mit entschieden haben uns ist jetzt
zugeschaltet herr gerne und herr gerne
er gerne aus bayern opernsänger in
bayern
herr gerne sie haben gerade lukas
podolski
gehört der gesagt habe wir brauchen
jetzt dringend wieder zuschauer
erklären sie uns wie geht es ihnen wie
geht es der kulturszene und was würden
sie sich von minister sparen wünschen
also erstmal herzlichen dank für das
dabei sein dürften in dieser sendung
ich bin übrigens in berlin und nicht
ausreichen und
die frage die sich stellt fragen was für
die kulturszene im moment zu machen ist
das sehr komplexe das ist eben nicht mit
dem fußball das ich begreife dass man
nicht von heute auf morgen die seele
wieder füllen kann
auf der anderen seite gibt es zu viele
grundsätzliche diskrepanzen in der
ausbeutung was gestattet ist und was
nicht gestattet ist alles nehmen wir das
beispiel zum beispiel jetzt der
glücklich verlaufen salzburger
festspiele wo in jeder veranstaltung
1000 leute im schacht mit prinzip sowohl
in großen als auch im kleinen haus in
salzburg den konzerten folgen durften
die aufführung theateraufführungen
gesehen hab ich frage mich warum nimmt
das so viel zeit
dieses gelungene konzept wo man
nachweislich bis jetzt nicht ein
einziger fall unter den zuschauern
diagnostizieren konnte warum wird
zusätzlich sofort aufgegriffen und und
es gibt zu zögerlich weiter in einer
szene die in existenzielle
schwierigkeiten gekommen ist dem die
frage direkt weiter gerne warum so
zögerlich erst mal ich sage noch einmal
das ding der verhandlung schutz und wir
haben gesehen es gibt bestimmte
situationen wo dieses virus sich leider
besonders gut verbreitet und das ist
insbesondere wenn im geschlossenen raum
viele menschen eng beieinander sind und
im zweifel dann wird es noch schneller
das gilt nicht nur für dieses virus wenn
sie feiern so dass in europa wären sie
jetzt nicht alle schunkeln
da sitzen aber trotzdem eben im
geschlossenen raum viele menschen und
deswegen haben wir immer gesagt das ist
der bereich wo wir im zweifel zug um zug
als letztes wieder werden starten können
damit schule kita begonnen wir haben
wirtschaft handel begonnen
auch wichtig um arbeitsplätze zu sichern
ich weiß es geht auch um arbeitsplätze
und perspektive gerade auch für künstler
und und alle die in den theatern opern
in vielen anderen bereichen konzerte
arbeiten aber genau das was sie
angesprochen haben ob in salzburg meines
wissens ist sind zumindest in münchen
weiß ich sicher auch in der staatsoper
mit einigen hundert zuschauern schon
wieder
begonnen worden und in anderen bereichen
auch wird er auch da jetzt zug um zug
begonnen und und miteinander sozusagen
geübt wie kann es gelingen
infektionsschutz bestmöglichen in
balance zu bringen mit
alltagstauglichkeit für oper und konzert
und da bin ich übrigens wieder bei herrn
mail von vorhin wenn die maske da im
alltag ein unterschied macht und wir
dafür wieder opern beginnen lassen
können mit weniger zuschauern und wir
wissen schon den meisten opfern zählen
sitzt man schon sehr eng beieinander so
zumindest die ich so kennt das man dass
man dann eben mit ein paar regeln
abstand maske dann jetzt auch zug um zug
in den regelbetrieb wiederkommt und da
sehen wir ja immer mehr opern und
theater hätte er gerne sagen sie auch
noch mal wie dramatisch die situation
für sie und andere bereits jetzt ist und
ob das ganze vielleicht schon zu spät
kommt ich denke in sehr vielen fällen
kommt diese kommt diese lockerung zu
spät
die frage ist damit nicht der anderen zu
sparen die frage ist ein haus von 2400
plätzen in münchen warum dürfen jetzt
nachdem salzburg glücklich funktioniert
hat über vier wochen lang kein einziger
fall
warum darf in bayern dann eben nur 500
leute in einem der größten häuser
europas die andere seite die ich
wirklich gerne wird ist eine antwort
bekommen könnte
ich fliege jetzt gott sei dank die
konzerte ist die lust haben ich bin kurz
entspannung gewesen dann in frankreich
dann in polen
ich bin mit öffentlichen linien dorthin
geflogen
die flügel sind so voll wie es nur
irgendwie geht
die leute setzen zum größten teil die
masten auf das geld das selbe gilt für
die züge was ist der unterschied dass
ich mitteilen dass leuten in einem
flugzeug für vier stunden sitzen kann
oder drei stunden im zug sitze der
grammel von es spezielle regionalzüge wo
die leute sogar in den gängen stehen die
klimaanlagen mitunter wir so oft bei der
deutschen bahn nicht funktionieren
speziell im sommer muss man es auch was
ist die argumentation dafür dass das
geht und dann ist scheinbar keine gefahr
da aber in einer so passiven situation
wie die leute in einem
aussitzen vollkommen konzentriert mit
abstand opfern wir opfern wir unsere
kultur herr sparen opfern wir unsere
kultur
ich versteh ich verstehe das argument
gut und auch dieses sozusagen gefühl
dass da zwei oder drei oder fünf
verschiedene welten sind was wir
begonnen haben ist zu sagen wir fangen
in bestimmten bereichen etwas schneller
wieder an weil sie auch wichtig sind als
lebensadern etwa eben der öffentliche
nahverkehr für berufspendler für
schülerinnen und schüler oder auch der
flugverkehr für das wirtschaftliche
leben
ein wichtiger unterschied übrigens
zwischen dem flugzeug und der opa ist
die lüftung im flugzeug werden alle zwei
bis drei minuten die gesamte luft
ausgetauscht und durch hepa filter also
durch filter die auch viren entsprechend
herausfiltern können durch gebracht das
gelingt den wenigsten opernhäusern würde
ich jetzt mal sagen mit dem heutigen
stand dass das auch zu leisten in der in
der lüftungsanlage und deswegen haben
wir eben gesagt in bestimmten bereichen
gehen wir als erstes wieder ins risiko
hinein stärker dann jetzt schule kita
dann jetzt wirtschaft handel
aber und das ist ja das was sie
beschreiben sie sagen im zweifel mehr
als 500 wäre vielleicht auch gegangen
ist ihre einschätzung aber wir fangen
eben jetzt auch im bereich von kultur
und kunst wieder wieder an wir haben ja
auch sehr bewusst unterstützung und
überbrückungshilfen gegeben auch da
wären sie im zweifel sagen dass das
trägt natürlich auch nicht für immer ist
mir auch klar und ich verstehe sehr gut
ihre ihre situation
gleichzeitig erlebt ich diejenigen auch
in veranstaltungen die mir sagen ihr
lockert viel zu schnell viel zu viel
warum sind alle leute schon wieder
irgendwie in einem raum geschlossen
also wir haben in der gesellschaft
beides wir haben diejenigen denen alles
zu schnell schon geht an lockerungen die
sich sorgen machen dass wir wieder zu
stark ins risiko gehen und wir haben
andere die auch aus nachvollziehbaren
erwägungen ob es wirtschaftliche
erwägungen sind oder auch vergleiche mit
anderen situationen seien das müsste
schneller gehen das müssen wir in der
balance bringen miteinander und das
finde ich wenn jetzt bei opern und
theatern ist auch wieder losgeht eben
mit konzepten
das gelingt uns jetzt zug um zug immer
besser herzlichen dank herr gehören auf
ihre ausführung und ihrem flammenden
appell für die kultur wir möchten
sprechen ersparen über die frau
wie gefährlich corona den tatsächlich
noch ist und wenn wir uns die
statistiken anschauen gab es gestern
laut lka die einen todesfall ist das
nicht am ende die entscheidende zahl
es ist eine wichtige zahl ich finde
wichtig da habe ich von anfang an für
geworben
diese pandemie und die dynamik nicht auf
eine zahl zu reduzieren wir haben die
verweise wird immer auf die infektion
star reduziert wenn sie sprechen die
regierung wenn ich immer groß und wetter
für andere in der regierung und aber die
kanzlerin spricht immer von wir sprechen
alle ethnien wir sprechen auch von
infektionszahlen herrnsheimer aber
wichtig ist doch die zahl der aktion
jakl ausschließlich von infektionen darf
ich kurz sagen
entscheidend ist zum einen die zahl der
neuinfizierten am tag das sagt nämlich
auch was darüber hinaus wie gut die
gesundheitsämter auch hinterher kommen
können mit kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung und andere mehr
entscheidend ist die dynamik ist es
stabil zeigte stark geht es zurück
entscheidend ist was welche folgen hat
das für das gesundheitswesen dazu
gehören erst mal bevor es auch um
sterblichkeit geht ja vor allem die
frage intensiv medizin und beatmung und
da sind wir gerade in der situation
meist richtig im kopf habe gerade um die
130 beatmete patienten in deutschland
mit kurven 19 das ist eine sehr geringe
zahl damit kann das gesundheitswesen
sehr sehr gut umgehen stand heute wir
sehen eben eine sterblichkeit auf
niedrigem niveau
und das alles zeigt uns verbunden zum
beispiel wohl hoffe ich auch immer
schauen wie ist das durchschnittsalter
in der jeweiligen woche der
neuinfizierten und wir sehen halt das
ist sehr stetig gesunken über die
letzten wochen
das heißt also es infizieren sich immer
mehr jüngere und bei unter 60 jährigen
das sehen wir auch in der statistik ist
das risiko von schwersten verläufen von
krankenhaus von intensiv eben deutlich
geringer aber trotzdem ich habe vorhin
gesagt wir leben nicht generationen
getrennt und muss natürlich immer die
dynamik im blick
deswegen bin ich sehr dafür immer das
runde bild zu zeichnen und genau alle
diese zahlen gleichzeitig in den blick
zu nehmen und abzuwägen
dennoch möchte ich noch mal auf eine
zahl eingehen in berlin gab es gestern
stand gestern 80 aktive fälle in ganz
deutschland 988 rechtfertigt das wird
1988 aktive völlig neuer infektionen
rechtfertigt das die einschneidenden
maßnahmen die frage ist doch was sind
denn tatsächlich jetzt noch die
einschneidenden maßnahmen also wo haben
wir noch wirklich einschneidende
maßnahmen das sind die bereiche von
kunst und kultur die in teilen noch
stark beschränkt sind
wir haben die bereiche von feiern club
szene partys weil wir eben sehen ob ich
gilt ob karneval ob hochzeit feiern wenn
jemand mit im raum ist der auch
infiziert ist dann sind das genau die
anlässe wo es dann sehr schnell sich
verbreiten kann
aber ansonsten haben wir doch in den
allermeisten lebensbereichen
mittlerweile wieder einen regelbetrieb
unter corona bedingungen heißt also mit
abstand hygiene alltags masken aber ich
finde wenn wir einfach mal darauf
schauen wo tatsächlich überhaupt noch
einschränkungen und beschränkungen sind
wenn man jetzt die maske zwar als nervig
aber als doch dann bildes mittel nimmt
sind wir alles in einem doch schon ein
ziemlich weiten weg aus der situation im
märz auch in mir bitte eine sache sie
unter dem alten präsidium dabei wenn die
kanzlerin spricht jetzt hat sie zwei
wochen hintereinander davon gesprochen
dass die züge länger geschnallt werden
müssen in der einen woche und in der
nächsten woche hat es in der internen
sitzung gesagt noch enger wenn sie diese
sprache hören können sie damit was
anfangen züge länger schneien
ich weiß gar nicht wer von uns waren ja
in seinem präsidiumssitzung teilnimmt
herrnsheimer hat dass sie immer besser
wissen als alle anfang also gesagt wurde
aber unabhängig davon züge länger
schneide unabhängig unabhängig davon
müssen wir doch die balance finden und
das sagt ja auch die frau
bundeskanzlerin zwischen einer
wachsamkeit und gleichzeitig aller
ernsthaftigkeit und gleichzeitig nicht
nicht nicht endzeitstimmung wir sind bis
hierhin gut durchgekommen
die lage heute ist eine gute weil es
unter kontrolle ist stand heute
und gleichzeitig müssen wir einfach
aufpassen dass wir nicht in so eine
dynamik rein kommen wie wir sie in
spanien sehen für mich ist dass ich wenn
ich mit meinem spanischen kollegen
telefoniere regelmäßig denn dann finde
ich das schon fast tragisch es gibt kaum
ein land in europa das mit härteren
maßnahmen ich habs gerade schon mal
gesagt militär auf der straße
passierscheine familien über wochen
maximal eine halbe stunde stunde raus
durften aus ihren wohnungen
kaum ein land das mit härteren maßnahmen
dieses virus unter kontrolle gebracht
hat die dynamik und wo es jetzt auf
einmal so entglitten ist und das möchte
ich einfach für deutschland vermeiden
ich möchte dass wir ein realistisches
bild haben dass wir miteinander wachsam
sind aber eben auch nicht im alarm modus
die ganze zeit wenn jeden tag alarm ist
es irgendwann gar keinen alarm mehr
sondern dass wir einfach mit der nötigen
aufmerksamkeit ernsthaftigkeit aber auch
zuversicht mit dem was wir schon
geschafft haben bin ich zuversichtlich
wenn wir miteinander und beieinander
bleiben werden wir noch die nächsten
monate gut hinbekommen lassen sie mich
noch einmal über sie sagen wobei sie
nach haben wir werden uns immer im raum
in dem alle modus sein
gehen wir noch einmal zurück auf die
sprache wenn wir über die vergangenen
monate sprechen dann war kurz nach dem
lauf dann hat die kanzlerin vor öffnungs
diskussionsforen gewarnt dann wurde von
der oster welle gewarnt dann vor der
pfingst welle und schließlich davor dass
nach dem urlaub alles ganz schlimm kommt
und jetzt kommt angeblich die herbst
welle
warum dieser alarmismus wenn wir diese
zahlen sind die frage ist ja immer was
hat was zur folge
das ist wie gesagt dieses präventions-
paradox ja auch wenn wir alle in einer
besonderen wachsamkeit und in einer
besonderen ja aufeinander aufpassen
modus sind die allermeisten bürger sagen
ja sie wollen sich und ihre mitbürger
ihre familie die die mit denen sie
zusammen sind mit in denen sie zusammen
im flieger vielleicht auch sitzen sie
wollen aufeinander aufpassen und uns so
lange wir das miteinander machen kommen
wir durch all diese zeiten gut durch
wenn wir das auch im urlaub machen
könnten wir auch in urlaub fahren wir
haben nur gesehen dass ist im urlaub
wir haben es beim spiel jetzt einmal
gesehen und wir haben jetzt noch mal bei
einem sommer rückreiseverkehr zumindest
bei bestimmten situationen gesehen es
war einmal der partyurlaub und teilweise
der verwandtschaft versuch wo wir dann
gesehen haben dass die zahlen wieder auf
einmal stärker gestiegen sind als wir es
jedenfalls erwartet hatten weil in
ländern wie spanien und dem westbalkan
auf 100 dynamik da war die nach die ich
jedenfalls nach den harten maßnahmen
diesen ländern so nicht erwartete heißt
also mit der mobilität entstehen
zusätzliche risiken und darauf
hinzuweisen darum ging es ja in all
diesen diskussionen und vor allem
deutlich zu machen wenn wir aufeinander
aufpassen dann besteht auch
ein anlass zur größeren sorgen aber am
sie das gefühl dass in der debatte auch
was andere politiker sagen zuviel
alarmismus ist wenn wir uns diese
gesamten zahlen anschauen wir haben
gerade darüber gesprochen
eben nicht nur auf die infektionszahlen
zuschauen da denken sich doch die
menschen moment mal so gefährlich wie
uns einige politiker immer sagen wollen
ist es doch gar nicht
ich kann ja nur am ende immer für mich
sprechen und das was ich tue und wie
mein ansatz dabei ist als minister für
gesundheit ist schon sehr starken
schwerpunkt lege auf infektionsschutz
auf gesundheitsschutz vor allem der
schwächsten was mir echt noch in den
knochen ist ist wolfsburg würzburg die
ersten pflegeeinrichtungen wo wenn das
virus dann einmal in den
pflegeeinrichtungen ist es sehr brutal
zuschlägt gerade bei den schwächsten in
der gesellschaft und mir sehr wichtig
dass wir die schützen und dass wir
gleichzeitig immer wieder auch einordnen
wie ist der wissensstand wie ist er wie
entwickelt sich das wir haben heute
bessere therapien zb die ärzte haben
heute erste medikamente mit denen sie
sterblichkeit etwa in der
intensivmedizin senken können das heißt
also wir haben fortschritt wir sehen
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
medizinische erkenntnisse und können
dadurch besser als gesellschaft damit
umgehen wir wissen dass die masken
helfen wir wissen dass bestimmte gene
maßnahmen helfen und das immer wieder
einzuordnen
über die zeit das ist jedenfalls das
worum ich mich sehr bemühen und
gleichzeitig zu sagen das entscheidende
ist die beste waffe gegen dieses virus
ist dass wir einfach im alltag
aufeinander aufpassen
es waren wir möchten mit jemandem
sprechen den sie auch gut kennen
herr strick ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
virologe sie saßen schon häufiger
zusammen in diskussion heftig wenn sie
jetzt auf die situation schauen wann die
schulschließung ein fehler
ich denke wir sind durch verschiedene
phasen gegangen in dieser kann die niere
und ganz am anfang wussten wir ja alle
nicht umgekehrt zu tun hat es gab keine
gefahr und es ist ein bisschen müßig
jetzt zurück zu schauen ob das jetzt ein
fehler gewesen ist oder nicht besser ist
es ja vorauszuschauen zu dem zeitpunkt
damals wussten wir nicht wie das
virologische geschehen in den schulen
sein kann ob die kinder mehr infektiös
oder weniger infektiös sein könnte man
hätte es wahrscheinlich genauso auch
offen sein lassen können die schulen
aber das wurde eben nicht gemacht aber
das war wirklich das nicht sagen dass
das ein fehler war aber gab es zu viel
oder gibt es aus ihrer sicht zu viel
alarmismus in der diskussion
ich denke auch dort haben wir
verschiedene phasen und ich hoffe dass
wir jetzt eigentlich in eine phase
eintreten wo wir mehr pragmatismus haben
wir wissen wir können das virus
mittlerweile sehr gut einschätzen
wir wissen dass es ein gipfel ein risiko
haftet virus ist aber wie es auf der
gleichen seite nicht überdramatisieren
müssen weil das risiko für den einzelnen
menschen recht gering es aber natürlich
für bestimmte risikogruppen recht dann
doch höher sein kann
wir können aber damit jetzt umgehen und
daher würde ich mir auch wünschen dass
wir das eben auch weiterhin gemeinsam
meistern als eine klasse es gibt kein
bundesland gross einen klassenbesten
gibt sondern die ganze klasse muss jetzt
hier bei bestehen
und ich sehe aber auch in der politik
ganz egal welchen kurs das ist dass man
aus diesen neuen erkenntnissen im moment
lernt und auch neue die maßnahmen neu
evaluiert und vielleicht auch andere
implementiert diese phase von alarmismus
ist eigentlich hoffe ich mittlerweile
auch schon passé sondern wir gehen eher
in die phase des pragmatismus ersparen
haben sie am anfang zu viel aufwand
osten und zu wenig auf den strick gehört
ich habe immer wert darauf gelegt viele
meinungen und einschätzungen zu hören im
übrigen so sehr ich herrn professor
strege und herrn professor drosten
schätze
ist gibt es ja auch über die virologen
hinaus noch die hygieniker die
intensivmediziner die pneumologen die
lungenärzte die die raum techniker nicht
raumlufttechnik nicht die luftfahrt
raumlufttechnik also ich habe jedenfalls
und bemühe mich bis heute darum sehr
rundes bild zu kriegen auch aus ganz
unterschiedlichen wissenschaftsbereichen
und gleichwohl bleibt eben eines dass
wir im märz eine deutlich andere wissens
lage dynamik und situation hatten als
heute und jede der entscheidungen die
wir getroffen haben haben wir getroffen
um zu schützen um gesundheit bestmöglich
zu schützen und menschen bestmöglich zu
schützen um infektionsrisiken zu
reduzieren bei einem virus das eben
damals noch weniger bekannt war als
heute auch heute wissen wir bei weitem
noch nicht alles schon gar nicht über
langzeitfolgen auch das muss man mal
dazu sagen wir sehen bei einigen
patienten jedenfalls bis hierhin schon
auch längere schäden da wo es wo es
schwerere verläufe gegeben hat also wir
können dieses virus noch nicht
abschließend einschätzen aber wir können
besser damit umgehen sagte aus einem aus
einer totalen unsicherheit
februar märz wird zug um zug um zug ein
risiko mit dem wir wie mit anderen
risiken weil das ganze leben ist ja am
ende risiko mit anderen risiken des
lebens auch umgehen können werden und
ist jeden tag besser lernen aber ich
finde so lange man eine unsicherheit hat
und dinge nicht weiß ist in der politik
so ist jedenfalls mein ansatz als
bundesminister für gesundheit
im zweifel eben auch ein besonderer
fokus auf die sicherheit er strebe keine
abschluss frage an sie gehören da aus
der politik ganz viele verschiedene
signale zum einen gibt es markus söder
und zum beispiel auch annegret kramp
karrenbauer die immer wieder warnen und
sagen die bevölkerung muss beschützt
werden und es gibt vielleicht wieder
einen lock down wie nehmen sie das wahr
wie nehmen sie die politik momentan war
und dabei auch entspannen
erst kann muss man ja realisieren dass
das virus sei von unserem alltag
geworden ist wird bleiben und auf diese
situation müssen wir uns einstellen ich
glaube zu warnen
bringt nichts wenn man nicht auch
gleichzeitig pragmatische lösungsansätze
bringt herrn sparen wiederum finde ich
hat sehr viele lösungsansätze immer
wieder angeboten und hat auch sehr
situativ eigentlich gehandelt und die
massnahmen angepasst und auch viele
experten befragt wie es eben auch schon
gesagt hat macht er ja auch seine
expertenrunden und lässt viele
verschiedene sichtweisen zu gehör kommen
aber ich denke dass es generell in der
politik eben man unterscheiden muss wäre
jetzt spricht also dass wenn er sich
ministerpräsidenten vielleicht
gegeneinander aufbauschen dass das
vielleicht nicht zielführend es habe ich
denke im moment oder zu vor allem zum
anfang der politik hat die
bundesregierung sehr gut und
folgerichtig gehandelt und jetzt wo wir
in dem risiko sind also nicht mehr in
der gefahr begeben jetzt auch die
diskussion was der richtige pragmatische
lösungsansatz wäre auch für verschiedene
bereiche
herzlichen dank dass sie sich heute
zugeschaltet haben und alles gute herr
sparen wir wollen noch einmal auf die
aktuellen forderungen kommen die gerade
in der debatte eine rolle spielen
bundespräsident steinmeier hat jetzt ein
staatsakt für corona opfer wie in
spanien ins spiel gebracht unterstützen
sie diese initiative dass wir
miteinander als nation als gesellschaft
auch einen weg finden vor allem auch ja
derart zu gedenken für die ja es hat war
im alltag im übrigen auch sehr grausam
harte situation hier entstanden sind
gerade die besuchsverbot in der
pflegeeinrichtung und auch derer zu
gedenken die eben dieser pandemie zum
opfer gefallen sind kann ich
grundsätzlich nur nur richtig finden die
frage ist in welcher form und zu welchem
zeitpunkt die wird jetzt sicherlich hat
der herr bundespräsident ja auch
angekündigt er besprechen mit weiteren
verfassungsorganen aber es ist schon
auch wichtig finde ich wer zu zeigen
dass wir wahrnehmen
welche herten welches leid es auch eben
gegeben hat und zum teil bis heute noch
gibt das also auch in aller abwägung und
bei aller unterstützung auch für die
politik cep in großen teilen der
bevölkerung gleichzeitig für viele das
auch mit verzicht mit einschränkungen
und wie gesagt auch zum teil mit sehr
harten leid verbunden war die letzte
frage zum thema corona sie haben gesagt
mit dem wissen von heute hätte man
altenheime und friseure vielleicht nicht
mehr schließen müssen dann müsste man
sie nicht mehr schließen kann es sein
dass sie in ein paar monaten auch sagen
werden mit dem wissen von dann von in
der zukunft hätte es auch dann keine
geschäfts schulschließungen geben müssen
was ich gesagt habe herr ronzheimer ist
zum ersten wir wissen heute eben anders
als noch im februar mehr als dass die
aha regeln abstand hygiene alltags maske
in bestimmten bereichen wirklich den
entscheidenden unterschied machen auch
ausreichend machen etwa eben im
einzelhandel beim einkaufen in der
gastronomie wenn alle aufeinander
aufpassen beim friseur
ich habe übrigens gesehen ja auch hier
bei bild.de dass da einige friseure
sagten dass sie das was ich ja nach
finden kann das waren ja für jemand der
selbstständig ist oder die für die
beschäftigten harte wochen wo man nicht
weiß wie geht s weiter überlebt mein
unternehmen mein geschäft mein
friseurgeschäftes wo viele dann sagen
erstmals stehen rund und was sagt ihr
denn da jetzt ich habe aber auch andere
gehört auch mein friseur hat mir das
zurückgespiegelt der ihm gesagt hat ich
bin eigentlich sehr dankbar dass ich
jetzt wenigstens weiß dass es weitergeht
weil dieses wald natürlich die
überschrift zweite welle die viele dann
immer larsen erstmal die frage hat
stellen lassen werden wir bald wieder
geschlossen
und ich fand es eben auch einfach
wichtig das signal zu geben eine
verlässlichkeit zu geben
das jedenfalls in den bereichen wenn wir
bei h bleiben keine schließung
infektiologe jedenfalls zum
infektionsschutz notwendig sind bei dem
besuch verboten ist es noch mal ein
stück stück anders sie waren damals
notwendig dringend notwendig dass dann
lege ich großen wert drauf weil das
wollen wir die schwersten härtesten
entscheidungen für uns
gesundheitsminister in den bundesländern
und im bund
ich hab vorhin wolfsburg und und und
würzburg erwähnt so als als als auch in
den medien ja
aber eben auch die ersten pflegeheime wo
das virus er dann wirklich viele
todesopfer mit sich gebracht hat brutal
zugeschlagen hat und das geht mir schon
nahe
solche situationen und wir haben
natürlich darüber beraten und darum
gerungen wie wir das vermeiden wie wir
die schwächsten die höchst betagten
schützen können
und da waren eben zuerst einmal die
besuchsverbot die auch hart waren also
das hat eher andersrum auch da waren
ehepaare die haben sich 40 jahre lang
jeden tag gesehen und konnten sich auf
einmal nicht mehr sehen und heute wissen
wir eben die konzepte sind entwickelt
besuchs beschränkungen gibt es noch aber
sind im konzepte entwickelt mit denen
das heute gehen kann und trotzdem das
ist mir sehr wichtig war das damals
notwendig und wirklich die aller
schwächsten zu schützen
die entscheidung ist echt ich kenne
keinen der 16 landeskollegen dem diese
entscheidung leicht gefallen ist ich war
neben dem thema corona beschäftigt die
welt momentan vor allem das schicksal
von herrn navalny der von hier nur
wenige kilometer entfernt immer noch im
koma in der charité liegt und wir wollen
uns einmal anschauen was dort passiert
ist
der putin-kritiker alexej nawalny so
stark so entschlossen wie in die welt
möglicherweise nie wieder sehen wird am
flughafen von toms wenig später
berichten aber nie zusammen vergiftet
dramatische szenen am flughafen
abtransport im rettungswagen
verhandlungen zunächst in einem
sibirischen krankenhaus bis in freunde
endlich nach berlin ausfliegen lassen
können landung in tegel einlieferung in
die charité
dort liegt navalny seit mehr als zwei
wochen im koma in seinem körper das
nervengift novica er sollte zum
schweigen gebracht werden alexei navalny
ist opfer eines verbrechens ersparen was
geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie das
sehen und 2018 haben sie gesagt es kann
nicht sein dass nord stream egal was
putin macht immer weiter geht kann nun
weitergehen
zuerst einmal können wir jedenfalls
nicht zur tagesordnung übergehen das ist
menschlich tragisch ist ein verbrechen
wie die frau bundeskanzlerin gerade
gesagt hat hat es ist politisch nichts
wo man jetzt einfach weitermachen kann
es nicht am ende und ich finde da der
außenminister die richtigen worte auch
heute gefunden auch sehr klar es liegt
jetzt an russland auch aufzuklären zu
informieren
aus dieser ja auch wenn ich manches
zitat auch heute sehe der trotzigen
haltung rauszukommen also was ist ihre
haltung kann nur 7 weiter gehen ja oder
nein ich habe doch gesagt ich finde der
außenminister das richtig ausgedrückt es
hängt jetzt daran ob und wie russland
mit dieser situation umgeht ob und wie
wir mit north stream zwei weiter umgehen
werden können das ist java russland
sagte wir haben ihn vergiftet
deutschland ist schuld das war ja das
ist ja keine aber auf fast warten sie
haben uns einmal am ende ist es ja keine
01 oder oder oder hat so ganz ohne
abgeschlossene frage
sondern am ende ja ein gesamtbild das
verhältnis die situation zwischen
deutschland und russland europa
europäische union und russland ist es ja
auch nicht das erste mal dass es zu
solchen situationen kommt im übrigen
auch ganz anders ukraine und andere
schwierige situation die in den letzten
jahren gesehen haben und am ende liegt
es tatsächlich an russland gerade jetzt
in diesen tagen und der bereitschaft
aufzuklären ist das ja entscheiden herr
merz hat gesagt ist braucht ein
moratorium erlassen hat gesagt es muss
weitergehen mit nord stream was ist ihre
haltung kleine haltung ist dass der ball
jetzt erstmal bei russland ist aber
russland hat dann gesagt deutschland ist
schon hier haben im großhandel ich von
russland erwarte dass da aufgeklärt wird
dass informiert wird dass hintergründe
gebracht werden
das ist ja bis jetzt kann nicht
abschließend aufgeklärt dieses
verbrechen das ist es ja nicht es muss
aber aufgeklärt werden
und es hängt sehr stark jetzt von
russland selbst ab und vom verhalten
russlands wie unser generelles
verhältnis zueinander ist deutschland
europäische union zu russland aber eben
auch wie es mit in ostritz weitergeht
wenn russland so weiter macht und sich
so äußert wie sich bisher geäußert haben
nämlich dass deutschland schuld ist dass
hannah war vergiftet wurde
was ist dann kann nord stream dann
weiter gehen ja oder nein ich sage noch
einmal sehr klar ist hat russland vor
allem in der hand ob und wie es mit
einer stimme zwei weitergehen kann
sie wollen sich da auf manifest liegt
das daran dass sie mit armin laschet
nein ist es nicht einfach daran es liegt
dafür ist diese frage und zwar nicht
zuerst wirtschaftlich ich finde es gibt
keine wirtschaftliche frage die am ende
wichtige wichtiger sein kann als außen-
und sicherheitspolitische interessen
deutschlands und europas
da gibt es für mich eine ganz andere in
der cdu positionieren sich ja klar aber
jetzt wäre meine gedanken gehen zu ende
machen in dieser frage bitte weil ich
finde sie ist zu wichtig als dass man
sie jetzt zur parteipolitischen fragen
irgendwie machen sollte es gibt am ende
keine wirtschaftspolitische fragen wie
welcher wichtiger ist als unsere außen-
und sicherheitspolitischen interessen
das ist für mich sehr sehr klar und
deswegen spielt das schon auch zusammen
und deswegen sind auch die prioritäten
da aus meiner sicht jedenfalls sehr sehr
klar
aber trotzdem muss man natürlich auch
den gesamtkontext zähnen da geht es um
viel in allen bereichen vor allem aber
auch für andere und für die frage wie
russland dort in dieser konkreten
situation agiert übrigens nicht zum
ersten mal nach allem was wir wissen und
deswegen sage ich noch einmal liegt es
jetzt auch an russland wie es weitergeht
letzte frage herr sparen zum
themenkomplex cdu wie es weitergeht in
ihrer partei aber auch in deutschland
wir sehen in allen umfragen markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident führt
unaufholbar so sieht es zumindest
momentan aus würden sie einen
kanzlerkandidaten markus söder
unterstützen etwa sind wir ja noch nicht
herbolzheimer wir sind erstmal dabei
einen neuen parteivorsitzenden zu wählen
im dezember und dann werden wir danach
im frühjahr denke ich einen
kanzlerkandidaten der union bestimmen
und ich bin sehr sicher wir werden den
oder diejenige auswählen die erstens von
der partei breit mitgetragen wird und
zweitens auch eine große chance darauf
hat dann auch kanzler kanzlerin zu
werden entscheidend ist ja nicht
kanzlerkandidat zu werden ich finde viel
wichtiger dass wir am ende auch den
kanzler stellen lassen sie uns einmal
hören was ihr parteikollege herr riedel
zur situation innerhalb der cdu gesagt
hat der chef des gesundheitsausschusses
und er hat eine klare meinung wäre
eigentlich partei positionieren soll
das wäre gut wenn wir mit einem starken
kandidaten im dezember antreten könnten
und dieser kandidat müsste nach meiner
meinung
jens spahn heißen weil er sich bewährt
hat er ist ein erfahrener finanz und
gesundheitspolitiker und hatte allen
festes wertegerüst transparent im handel
kritikfähig entscheidungsfreudig also
nach meiner meinung wenn da alle
fähigkeiten mit die man als
bundesvorsitzender einer großen
volkspartei haben muss um erfolg zu
haben
ersparen sie stehen auch in den umfragen
besser da als er laschet warum drehen
sie sich nicht umdrehen sie es nicht um
sie treten an und herr laschet wird der
stellvertreter armin laschet und ich
haben entschieden gemeinsam ein angebot
zu machen ich habe entschieden
vize vorsitzender der cdu zu kandidieren
und das geld das heißt ist bleibt bei
der entscheidung parteitag im dezember
und heißt dann der kann kanzlerkandidat
automatisch auch armin laschet der
kanzlerkandidat wird und das hat armin
laschet das haben übrigens alle drei
kandidaten für den vorsitz er sehr klar
deutlich gemacht dann gemeinsam mit der
csu so ist das gute tradition zwischen
den beiden schwesterparteien gemeinsam
mit der csu dominierte und festgelegt
aber genauso klar ist dass ein
cdu-bundesvorsitzenden cdu-parteichef
immer auch ein erstes zugriffsrecht auf
die kanzlerkandidatur hat das
entscheidung noch dieses jahr
naja der parteitag ist anfang dezember
ich denke dann kommt weihnachten und
dann wären wir das nächstes jahr
entscheiden
herzlichen dank herr sparen das sie sich
so ausführlich hier den fragen der
zuschauer gestellt haben dass sie sich
auch den fragen gestellt haben hier von
so vielen prominenten und jetzt ist
meine kollegin carina mößbauer bei mir
denn wir haben auch nach dem interview
mit den spar noch etwas vor was genau
hat tief in der natur sozusagen bei uns
geht es jetzt gleich weiter ich habe
vier sehr spannende gäste bei uns im
studio mit denen ich jetzt auch
aufmerksamen ihren auftritt verfolgt
habe und wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen
darüber sprechen themen gab es ja auf
jeden fall genug es lohnt sich also auch
für sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen bei
bild dranzubleiben und starten wollen
wir noch mal mit diesem moment
ich finde man kann die maßnahmen im märz
die damals richtig war nicht mit dem
wissen aus september dann bewerten also
man kann das machen aber die frage ist
ob das tatsächlich die richtige
herangehensweise ist und das sehe ich
halt anders sieht es da einmal beim
thema masken masten pflicht bleiben
sie waren bei der großdemo in berlin da
waren kaum masten zu sehen ich glaube
sie sind tatsächlich auch der
überzeugung dass diese maske nicht
braucht richtig der überzeugung bin ich
tatsächlich und zwar deswegen weil ich
glaube ich mit der meinung die ich eben
geäußert habe nicht alleine wenn wir
sparen sagt sondern es gibt viele
namenhafte wissenschaftler wie martin
hartl social web aktiv die bereits im
februar gesagt haben dass diese
maßnahmen nicht angebracht sind und das
ist in der wissenschaft gibt es einen
des kurses werden hypothesen aufgestellt
und diese prothesen haben sich bis jetzt
bewahrheitet diese wissenschaftler
gesagt haben und ihnen masken haben wir
nach überflüssig ich muss das alles ist
die masten zu einem argument von herm
etwas sagen ja es gibt es gab und gibt
wissenschaftler die das auch im februar
schon anders bewertet haben es gibt
übrigens auch viele andere
wissenschaftler also deswegen ist das ja
immer jeder sucht sich so sein raus am
ende gibt es einen unterschied zwischen
ihren mail herrn buckley und der
bundesregierung
wir mussten am ende entscheiden weil wir
verantwortung dafür haben was mit
menschen und menschen leben passiert das
eine ist ein buch zu schreiben
das andere ist zu wissen einer
unsicheren situation wo es ganz
unterschiedliche einschätzungen
eindrücke wissen stände gibt am ende
abzuwägen was geht in der unsicherheit
situation vor und wir haben tatsächlich
gesagt es geht vor allem auch der schutz
von leben und gesundheit vor
jetzt bei mir im studio meine kollegin
von bild patrick sehr platzierten
vertreten der chefredakteur von pioneer
sie müssen
rieke ehemalige chefredakteurin von
bunte sie strahlen mich an
mit ihnen würde ich auch gerne gleich
anfangen sie haben diesen auftritt auf
erfolgt gerade nochmal den letzten
ausschnitt gesehen zum thema maske ist
sparen denn da einfach in so einer
unglücklichen situation dass er sich
sozusagen er hat vom präventiv paradox
gesprochen also je mehr sich an die
maßnahmen gehalten wird desto besser
sind vielleicht die infektionszahlen und
auch desto besser kommt deutschland
durch die krise eher als
gesundheitsminister im permanenten
rechtfertigung mottos wie sehen sie es
ich habe ihn als inkompetent
entscheidungsfreudig und vor allem auch
jetzt erlebt also er redet manchmal so
ein bisschen um den heißen brei herum
aber er wird der sympathische in meinen
augen habe ich heute nicht einen
zupackenden minister erlebt sondern
einen kandidaten
denn auch wenn jens spahn sagt dass er
sich mit lasches geeinigt habe
auf vize aus dem vize posten
so ist es doch gibt es habe ich gehört
ja ja
cdu in der union gibt es bestrebungen
insider habe ich das gesagt habe mir das
gesagt dass man sich vorstellen könnte
lasche zu bewegen ob er nicht vielleicht
zugunsten von herrn spahn
vielleicht sich zurückzieht also dass
genau das stattfindet nämlich ein
wechsel der positionen und ich könnte
mir so einen jungen cdu csu vorsitzenden
sehr gut vorstellen
er ist jung dynamisch und hat diesen
schwiegersohn effekt
wenn man sich gerne unterhält also angst
man auch wenn er manchmal bisschen
heißen brei herumredet er redet um den
preis nach heißen brei herum aber frau
riekel hat hier brandheiße news corp was
dies was hast du denn so aus der cdu
erfahren wollen wir erstmal darüber
sprechen und dann noch mal zum gespräch
zurückkommen ist er möglicherweise doch
ende des jahres dann der cdu-chef und
wechselt das ist glaube ich selbst wer
wo menschen noch zu sehen aber eine
sache ist ja fürs sparen erst mal
wichtig er hat ja einmal versucht ist
auf den dritten platz reingekommen und
viele haben ja nachgesagt das thema
karrierist ist und immer nur versucht
den nächsten schritt anzupeilen und
diese rolle als gesundheitswesens natur
die wir eigentlich im moment ganz gut
weil er das nicht machen kann er muss
tatsächlich regierungspolitik umsetzen
er muss er musste seriös sacharbeit
leisten was ja auch sehr gut kann er
kommt ja aus diesem bereich und im team
mit laschet hat er sich ein sollte jetzt
eine zweite position er weiß auch dass
er diese position jetzt nicht infrage
stellen kann er kann nicht aus dieser
rolle angreifen heraus weil das all das
wieder zunichte machen würde was er
bisher erreicht hat also ich würd mal
sagen jetzt sparen würde sich nicht
ärgern wenn man ihn bitten würde am ende
derjenige zu sein der kanzlerkandidat
oder parteichef werden soll
aber er kann von seiner rolle aus herr
nur seine sache arbeit so gut wie
möglich machen und warten was andere
dann vielleicht ertragen sparen wird
sicherlich nicht nein sagen wenn er
gebeten und gefragt wird aber wie siehst
du es patricia du hast jetzt dieses
stunde erlebt hat da ein möglicher
cdu-spitzenkandidat sich jetzt
präsentiert oder glaubst du er bleibt
wirklich so im team laschet als nummer
zwei er hat im moment glaube ich keine
andere möglichkeit ist ja auch kein
smarter move jetzt nach vorne zu
preschen er hat dort sein wort gegeben
das hätte heute hier auch noch mal
bekräftigt und es wäre alles andere als
schlau sich jetzt da ins spiel zu
bringen ich glaube es ist wirklich auch
eher so wie es angesprochen würde wenn
er gebeten wird kann ich mir auch schwer
vorstellen dass er da zögern würde aber
diesen moment jetzt dafür zu benutzen
wer gänzlich das falsche da sind wir
wahrscheinlich alle noch ein bisschen zu
ungeduldig weil so schnell wird den erst
mal keiner beet muss sondern auch gar
nicht klar ob der parteitag überhaupt
statt wenn du hast etwas gelegt als hier
der heiße 3 angesprochen wurde war das
tier zu viel heißer prägt also ich
stimme zu dass ihr in spanien sehr
souveränen eindruck gemacht hat dazu
gehört ehrlich
der politik in letzter zeit ja dass man
um den heißen brei herumredet weil in
dem moment wo man die fakten klar
benennt und wo man sich positioniert ist
man schnell nicht mehr souverän weil wir
schon sofort angegriffen wird und er hat
im grunde keine angriffslinie geliefert
das muss er auch nicht als minister
ich finde dass die themen aus heutiger
sicht hätte man entscheidungen früher
anders treffen müssen tatsächlich die
schwierige debatte sind ich finde aber
dass man aus dieser erkenntnis dass man
heute anders
andere dinge weiß viel viel intensivere
schritte nach vorn gehen könnte man
könnte sie die die masken pflicht noch
mal genau vornehmen ich bin sowieso ein
absoluter gegner von pflichten ist das
gegenteil des mündigen bürgers
wir waren ihr sozusagen ja wann im
grunde entmündigt und ich glaube das
wäre eine masken pflicht verhängt
verhängt als nächstes die impfpflicht
und da wünsche ich viel spaß bei der
debatte
ich sehe hier schon kopfschütteln es
gibt ja durchaus leute die sagen bei uns
geht es also die a-ha regeln sind ja
noch genug zum leben sozusagen wie
siehst du es wird inhaltlich auch sofort
eingreifen
diese masken pflicht wird wie wir die
ganze zeit diskutieren wir erhalten uns
wir tragen etwas von den mund ich
verstehe gar nicht das scheint so zu
sein scheint das schlimmste sein und die
nachsorge zeit ist das vergessen hat was
man schon dramatisch aus volks ja das
macht das ganze dramatischer also
insofern wir haben etwas vor dem gesicht
das ist jetzt wirklich nichts schlimmes
und du sagst du hast keine pflicht nur
zahlt steuern da ist allerlei pflichten
sowie seinen beruf nach wir haben in
einer gesellschaft pflichten und genau
da haben wir pflichten wo es an die
unversehrtheit der anderen geht möchten
dieses grundgesetz was auch bei den
demonstrationen so hart diskutiert wurde
erinnern
und hier geht es eben um die
unversehrtheit der anderen und warum
fällt es uns allen so schwer weil es nur
um die unversehrtheit der anderen geht
wird es nämlich um den eigenen schutz
gehen wird es darum gehen dass erwiesen
wäre das die massen und total von corona
schützen würde keiner sich darüber
beschweren und wir werden alle mit
masken ja das ist ja sowieso klar dass
sie einen selber kaum schützen sondern
den andern das legte schon banal wie
absurd der ganze gedankengang ist ich
will daran erinnern dass die gesamtheit
der problematik außer acht gelassen ich
nehme ein beispiel von mir ja ich bin
umgestiegen vom auto auf die bahn vor
allem
zeit viel besser jetzt fahre ich nicht
mehr waren weil mich das nervt und
belastet die maske zwei oder drei
stunden auf der umfang wieder auto meine
meine drei stunden strecken mit dem
fahrrad dauern dann na ja ja ja aber der
russiche an den endpunkten ausführen ich
glaube dass dieses land das immer
sozusagen alle ermuntert an alle dinge
zu denken im moment viel zu monokausal
über masken über corona über
sterblichkeit diskutiert es gibt ja
keiner hat gelernt keine sterblichkeit
mehr
es war ein stresstest für das
gesundheitssystem
übrigens auf der ganzen welt und unser
gesundheitssystem hat am anfang mittel
gut abgeschnitten und jetzt sehr gut und
da wir jetzt wissen dass unser
gesundheitssystem darauf vorbereitet ist
könnte man viel viel intensivere
schritte hin zu einer normalität gehen
als das getan wird ich finde dass heute
sehr leicht sehr leichtfertig von
spannen darüber weg gegangen wurde wie
viele industrien durch diese maßnahmen
kurz vor dem ruin stehen wie viele
menschen arbeitslos geworden sind
wie viele menschen in kurzarbeit sind da
bleiben es jetzt auch länger finanziert
von der regierung über den wahltag
hinaus also das bedeutet er diese
wahrheiten sind nicht wirklich von ihm
heute thematisiert lockerungen und
maßnahmen vielleicht auch wieder
zurücknehmen nochmal weiter geben und
sagen ist sparen da nicht auch irgendwie
in der sehr sehr undankbare situation
weil er so qua amtes gesundheitsminister
irgendwie von allen so als einer der
hauptverantwortlichen gesehen wird aber
wie wir jetzt in den letzten
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen gesehen
haben haben dann doch eher die länder
chefs und chefinnen so das sagen und
jeder kocht sein eigenes süppchen oder
wie viel kann er denn da überhaupt noch
durchsetzen geordert der größte
moderator sozusagen oder moderator noch
mal eins in der ganzen rolle was
eigentlich überhaupt nicht seinen
politischen instinkt entspricht er ist
eigentlich eher jemand der guckt was
sind da für stimmungen auf der straße
nimmt die aufschlägt auch politisch
kapital draus das hat daher nach der
flüchtlingskrise gemacht hat er sehr
früh erkannt da gibt es eine stimmung
auf der straße
die ist nicht zufrieden mit dem was die
regierung macht und hat sehr sehr früh
diese stimmung aufgenommen und für sich
auch genutzt in weitere karriereschritte
das kann ja jetzt nicht so machen erst
in einer anderen rolle er ist nicht mehr
derjenige der von außen an greift er ist
in einer wirklich ersten reihe der
regierung in
in der wichtigsten oder einer der
wichtigsten rollen für die bekämpfung
der korona pandemie und hat tatsächlich
ist er wirklich ein moderator auch wenn
man sich das spektrum an guckt er bewegt
sich immer ungefähr in der mitte von den
meinungen der ministerpräsident ich
würde gern einmal noch zur frau rieke
geben sie haben gerade gelegt ist er in
der moderator rolle sehen sie da auch
und schwierig rauszukommen
er ist auf alle fälle ein gewinner der
korona krise sowieso und das hat er auch
glaube ich sehr schnell kapiert und er
ich finde auch dass er sich immer in der
mitte bewegt und das machte aber
ziemlich gut wenn man bedenkt was für
was man machtinstinkt eigentlich
normalerweise hat aber ich glaube schon
dass er in die zukunft denkt und er sich
nicht als lasche spahn gespannt sondern
eher als mann
wiederspahn oder sparen sowie wie auch
immer söder als silber als kanzler der
auch gefragt werden möchte und sparen
er müsste dann auch gefragt werden aber
wie gesagt es gibt bestrebungen in der
union zugunsten von also verlass nach
vorne zu schieben
das lassen wir also dass er gesagt und
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen er
selber wird das natürlich nicht
vorschlagen er ist klug und wartet bis
man ihn dazu drängen so klaus hat hier
auch nochmal ich erstmal eigentlich die
analyse des moderators brillant ich
glaube sogar noch eins dazu sagen zu
wollen so wie ich hier einsparen jetzt
seit 19 jahren aus der halbdistanz
wahrnehme glaube ich sogar dass er
teilweise gegen seine eigentliche
überzeugung handelt ich würde es
ableiten aus seiner hinführung zu der
krise wo er sehr spät zu entschiedenen
maßnahmen gegriffen hat wo zunächst
gesagt man müsse sich keine sorgen
machen
deutschland sei gut vorbereitet wurde
dann dazu gelernt hat wie wir alle aber
tief in sich drin glaube ich ist er zwar
kein corinna leugner oder kurven oder
maßnahmen aber es auf jeden fall nicht
das schaf macher unter lockdown lockdown
sondern er ist eigentlich tendenziell
eher bei denen die sagen kommt macht mal
halblang und sperrt langsam wieder auf
und ab und zu tun dass durch das finde
ich sehr sehr sympathisch nämlich zum
beispiel mit dem satz der so viel
diskutiert worden ist mit dem wissen von
heute hätte man manches anders machen
können einsatz von vor vier wochen
wir werden uns vieles verzeihen müssen
das gibt es nur wenn du tief in dir drin
sozusagen spürst so ganz in meinem navi
bin ich nicht und ein wort muss ich
schon auch noch zum zum kanzler
möglichen kanzlerkandidaten sagen also
politik ist ja in gewisser weise kein
wunschkonzert sondern gnadenlos und
folgt bestimmten formalen gegebenheiten
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht gibt
es ein cdu-parteitag wenn es ihn gibt
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht die
entspannt da gar nicht an sondern es
treten laschet märz und röttgen an einer
von denen wird es das heißt armin
laschet als cdu-chef kann nur armin
laschet verhindern indem er die nerven
verliert oder indem er gedrängt wird die
macht die ihm damit zukommt nicht
anzunehmen
so habe ich armin laschet nicht
wahrgenommen und übrigens dann wenn das
passiert kommt sofort die frage auf
warum sollen wir denn den jens nehmen
dann immer durch über den micro aus
bayern
da immer noch mehr chancen und sozusagen
auf eine formel gebracht einer muss
laschet killen wenn er sich nicht selber
gilt das kann nicht jens spahn sein weil
dazu zu klug ist da schließe ich mich an
aber dieses gebeten werden seinen
eigenen ich sage jetzt mal chef
sozusagen in diesem ensemble aus dem
rennen zu schubsen
daran glaube ich nicht vor allem mit
einem ganz banalen indiz jens spahn ist
40 er hat noch ganz ganz ganz ganz lang
zeit kanzler zu werden
armin laschet ich und das stimmt weiß
auch wie es anders werden würde das
vielleicht meinen freuen aber wenn ich
mich heute festlegen müsste würde ich
sagen
laschet wird und macht es auch diese
runde wollte ich später noch mal stellen
aber heute geht es wild durcheinander
ich wollte noch mal dich fragen vertritt
sehr optisch ähnlich wahrgenommen hat
wie klaus der sagt eben eigentlich ist
er ja gar nicht so ein hardliner
eigentlich möchte er manchmal gerne
anders aber ist so sozusagen gibt
getrieben von der gruppendynamik im
kabinett hat das gefühl dass er sich da
manchmal heute auf die zunge beißen
musste und eigentlich gerne ein bisschen
hatte ich dieses gefühl ich glaube er
hat genau das wiedergegeben was er sagen
wollte und das glaube ich auch in
beobachtung der ganzen krise was er
sagen wollte als wir so angegriffen weil
diese szene also angesprochen als er
sagte wir konnten den märz nicht mit dem
wissen aus september beurteilen hat er
genau das gemeint er ist mit einer krise
umgegangen die völlig unvorhersehbar und
unberechenbar war deswegen war ihm auch
klar ist er sagte wir werden uns einiges
zu verzeichnen haben war ihm klar dass
dieser punkt gibt weil es nicht möglich
ist in dieser krise nur richtige
entscheidungen zu treffen und es sollte
uns auch mal ganz klar sein es ist nicht
möglich und das war ihm bewusst ich
denke diese einsicht ist sehr schlau
dass zu diesen beginnen gleich so zu
sehen
und ich glaube überhaupt nicht dass er
eigentlich quasi deiner sicht ist und
sich wahnsinnig viele lockerungen herbei
würde ich habe ihn als sehr authentisch
wahrgenommen ich glaube dass er
tatsächlich schritt für schritt gehen
möchte und schauen möchte was die
lockerungen führen
wir haben jetzt hier freund schon gehört
sparen ist der gewinner dieser krise
also in der tat ist es ja auch so
dass man kaum einen gesundheitsminister
in den letzten jahren so auf dem schirm
hatte und dass jemand so im fokus stand
wie er jetzt wo würdest du denn bei wert
schon so viel darüber sprechen dass er
vielleicht doch mal übernimmt wo siehst
du seine stärken
ich glaube er ist ein sehr guter
rhetoriker ist es intelligent er kann
politische prozesse durchblicken er ist
auch furchtlos das ist glaube ich alles
attribute die auf ihn zutreffen ich
glaube was die debatte vorher angeht ich
glaube das stimmt der macht schon das
was er für richtig hält aber er macht
eben das was er in seiner rolle jetzt
für richtig hält und er ist der
gesundheitsminister und er wird gemessen
an krankenhausbetten an der frage ob die
intensivstation überlassen ob die
beatmungsgeräte alle da sind und so
weiter und so fort und wenn du nach
diesen kriterien bemessen wirst in
deiner politischen leistung dann achtest
du eben auf all diese virologischen
maßnahmen so zu sagen was da empfohlen
wird und nicht wie ein ministerpräsident
auch noch guckt auf fußball stadien auf
unternehmen und auf die sonstige
stimmung in der bevölkerung ich glaube
schon deswegen auch das was claus strunz
sagt jens spahn in einer anderen rolle
jeder anderen rolle als mir als
gesundheitsminister auf
ministerpräsident außerhalb des
kabinetts wo auch immer würde ganz
anders agieren in dieser krise da schon
na ja er würde er ist ein mann der
straße von der politischen stimmung
ergreift er das gerne auf das sieht man
ja auch in dem moment in dem man
natürlich nicht ohne hintergedanken sich
mit einer laufenden kamera vor die
grölende menge stellt sondern er weiß
genau dass er auch als politiker stärke
zeigt dadurch dass er sich anschreien
das in dem moment also dass diese
instinkte hat er schon und
erhört dahin wie gesagt das hat der
flüchtlingsrat auch gemacht das würde er
jetzt wahrscheinlich auch sagen es ist
müßig darüber zu diskutieren er ist
gesundheit wenn es da aber das ist eine
rolle aber ich glaube wenn man ihn und
seine leistung einsortiert dann muss man
das sich einmal auch angucken rauch
rieche ich würde sie gern noch mal hier
in die diskussion holen spahn hatte ja
vorhin gesagt nicht ich bin der
spielverderber sondern das virus also
als er wirklich permanent in diesen
rechtfertigungszwang man möchte auch
aktuell nicht wirklich mit ihm tauschen
bei dieser verantwortung sie als
bürgerin des landes haben sie das gefühl
dass war dass sie in guten händen sind
finden sie so alles in allem hat er uns
gut durch die krise geführt oder
verstehen sie auch den einen oder
anderen der sagt es war zu viel wir
müssen auch mal mehr wieder auf die
wirtschaft gucken und da sind eben nicht
nur ihre die vor zwei wochen in berlin
auf die straße gegangen sind
es ist ein bisschen kompliziert darauf
zu antworten auf der einen seite bin ich
gern mal dass viele maßnahmen
übertrieben waren und sind ja kinder zum
beispiel masken die schule zu schicken
schuhen zu schießen und zu schließen und
so weiter also das finde ich alles
übertrieben andererseits hat mir sehr
gut gefallen wie spannend wird diese
krise uns alle geführt sagt ja ich habe
es immer sehr schön erklärt und mir
gefällt auch dass er heute sagt dass wir
jetzt im september viele dinge anders
beurteilen werden als im märz das mir
nicht gut und ich schätze politiker die
so geradeaus sind und die auch sondern
seine stärke haben und das wird ihm auch
in der zukunft positiv auf dann auf
seine karriere aus wenn aber die
tatsache dass sich um den heißen brei
herum reden kann und sich dann genau
belegt welchen standpunkt bereinigen
soll das hat man ja gemerkt weiter
fragen das trotzdem 2 also was soll
jetzt geschehen und russland muss zuerst
reagiert da dass ich nicht dass ich
nicht auch etwas festlegen wollen
da ist also sehr vorsichtig das ist nur
also wirklich aufgefallen zum vorsichtig
in dieser krise als gesundheitsminister
spannung sagen was seine
gesundheitsminister zu nord stream sagen
da ist er zu recht gehört haben nicht in
seiner prokura und da hält er sich
natürlich aus das kann man jetzt als
bürger schade finden politisches
sicherlich geschickt er hat ja auch
gesagt gar keine fehler zu machen ist
unmenschlich wir haben ihm nochmal
dieses foto vorgehalten im lift ich
gedrängt setzen wir unmenschliche
standards und zwischen machen unsere
politiker an patricia ich glaube nicht
nur an unsere politiker ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt an uns alle also wenn es
so einen weil sie aufschrei zur folge
hat dass ein politiker mal sagt ja das
hätte man anders machen können und wir
tatsächlich dann diskutieren was das mit
seinem image oder seinem standing macht
dann glaube ich haben wir eine falsche
fehlerkultur es ist völlig normal dass
wir fehler machen und ich hoffe dass
unsere politiker auf fehler machen und
sich dann hinstellen und sie eingestehen
wir müssen noch eher misstrauisch werden
bei denen die sie die ganze zeit
allwissend geben den muss unser
misstrauen gelten indes insofern fand
ich dass ein sehr großer moment also ich
hätte dazu eine andere haltung ich finde
es menschlich nämlich es ist menschlich
eine zierde fehler zuzugeben wenn es ein
bisschen viele fehler werden hätte ich
gern andere politiker die an die stelle
treten mit dem anspruch keine fehler zu
machen wir können uns ja nicht darauf
einigen dass politiker munter vor sich
hin fehler machen können und wir sagen
einmal acht dame hat zu viel stress
ach der arme so viel zu tun ach das
thema ist wirklich schwierig ach mensch
heute weiß man es besser als früher
das ist mir eine zu große wenn du sagst
wir haben eine nicht fahren die
fehlerkultur dann ist mir das eine zu
intensiv ausgeprägte verzeihung skulptur
weil ein mensch hat ein amt und wird
dafür bezahlt und hat die verantwortung
dinge zu entscheiden und wenn er zu oft
daneben liegt dann soll das jemand
anders versuchen so dass auch mein
findest und demokratie zu verstehen es
geht um die transparenz und das
verlangen von den politikern
damit heißt es nicht dass jeder fehler
entschuldigt ist wir haben ihn ja nur
ein ganz klar konfrontiert mit diesem
foto nochmal und er hat eben gesagt na
ja am anfang wie für uns alle
wahrscheinlich schwierig diese neuen für
uns allen neuen regeln zu verinnerlichen
wie kannst du ihn in dem moment von zehn
glaubhaft fenster also dass die antwort
eben hat die dich überzeugt oder sie ist
es auch er bisher bei klaus und sagst
gerade er als gesundheitsminister sowas
darf nicht passieren
ich glaube ehrlich geantwortet hätte
in dem moment gesagt ich bin da als
erster eingang oder als zweiter in
fracks durchstand am rand ich weiß auch
nicht warum die sich alle noch mal mehr
rein gedrängt haben endlich und in der
sekunde steht der fotograf da und nimmt
auch noch auf ich glaube das wäre die
ehrliche antwort gewohnt warum gibt ein
politiker die ehrliche antwort nicht
weil er dann sorge hat dass er zwölf
andere leute beschuldigt dass die schuld
sind also verhält er sich in so einem
system modus also dass er sich dass er
in dem moment ich bin ich ehrlich
antwortet weil wir da natürlich das
stimmt schon in der debatte nicht
richtig funktionieren glaube ich und auf
der anderen seite zeigt dass eben auch
wie unglücklich diese situation war und
dieses bild darf so und nicht entstehen
das muss man verhindern dass man gerade
ich glaube es war im april da war es
wirklich eine sehr ernste situation und
dann so was da draußen zu sein frau
riekel sie wollten das auch noch mal
kommentieren ja ich wollte noch mal
sagen er hat ja auch gesagt dass er die
maske also die masken pflicht ging das
er gemacht freiwillig trägt aber das ist
ja nicht so gefangenen gemacht denn ich
freilich wir müssen sie ertragen wenn
wir sehen nicht tragen wollen müssen wir
endlich eine strafe zahlen
eine eigene regel kann man ja als
politiker darf auch die maske nicht
nicht tragen dann machte er sich als
politiker wieder angreifen ich finde die
nach den punkt 5 regel an der stelle
interessant weil einst zog sich für mich
ein bisschen zu deutlich durch dieses
gesamte interview
und zwar die versetzung der bürger in
den zustand des schülers also wir üben
alles miteinander
dann gibt es pflichten du du du du du
wenn du deine maske nicht aufsetzt musst
du jetzt ganz viel bezahlen wir haben es
aber mit erwachsenen menschen zu tun ich
möchte nicht angesprochen werden wie ein
kleinkind als bürger dieses landes und
diese diese terminologie in der
kommunikation ist glaube ich die
erklärung für vieles an gegenreaktionen
viele leute gehen die maßnahmen damit
aber sie wollen aufgeklärt und
angesprochen werden wie erwachsene
mündige menschen die ihre entscheidungen
selber treffen können und wenn ich auf
einem gang entlang gehe und es ist
keiner mehr da und links und rechts
kommt auch keiner aus den türen dann
mache ich die maske herunter und dann
kann keiner kommen und sagen du du du in
dem raum mit diesem haus ist aber masken
vielleicht und jetzt bist du dass du
etwas falsch gemacht das habe ich
entschieden übrigens in großer
verantwortung für alle anderen die gar
nicht da waren
und das finde ich das finde ich wie sage
männer wenn du das wär ist kannst du
sagen entschuldigung ich kann für mich
entscheiden ob ich über rot war wenn die
straße frei ist ich kann für mich
scheiden entscheiden ob ich zu viel
getrunken habe und noch auto fahren kann
es ist eben so dass es jährigen das
schwere ist dass es eine neue regel gibt
und das fällt uns immer schwer
irgendwann geht das in den alltag
ich möchte michael auch noch mal in die
diskussion holen sie haben genickt haben
sie sich zeitweise während dieser
pandemie wie an die schülerinnen gefühlt
und war das problem vielleicht wirklich
die kommunikation also die art und weise
wie eben diese pflicht an die schüler in
anführungsstrichen herangetragen wurde
ja ich habe nicht sehr oft gefühlt wenn
unmündiges kind nebenmann anweisungen
geben muss und ich glaube in der
kommunikation hätte vielleicht die
regierung das ein bisschen entspannter
und lässiger und machen können und mehr
auf die eigenverantwortung wochen
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig die
kanzlerin hat auch mal gesagt jetzt
machen muss die zügel anziehen jahr
würstchen werden über die kurze gespannt
werden müssen
wobei wenn man die zügel anzieht
passiert da was ganz anderes das pferd
geht nicht langsamer sondern geht
schneller voran hieß es
ja also sich sich ähnlich ich glaube
auch dass er da so ein bisschen
aufpassen muss aber die bestimmter im
brunnen und zu hören es gab einen
anderen sehr persönlichen momente als
wir herrn sparen nochmal dieses video
vorgespielt haben mit den also wirklich
angefeindet angepöbelt wurde sogar
angespuckt und er hat da doch relativ
abgebrüht reagiert und hat gesagt naja
widerspruch in der demokratie ist
erlaubt frau riekel sie kennen ihn auch
gut
nehmen sie ihn das ab oder wenn sie
sagen das geht eben doch näher und er
zeigt es einfach nicht also ich denke
dass er sehr professionell ist als
politiker und erkämpfte soße immer um
sympathie wird geschätzt
aber er wird nicht unbedingt immer
geliebt und das muss es sich erkämpfen
und ich finde dass er da das somit mit
andere meinungen und und demonstranten
sehr gut umgegangen
ist und das ist ein absoluter profi
patrick seeger im studio natürlich den
kopf ja das ist nämlich der einzige
punkt wir reden hier von professionell
umgehen da hätte ich mir tatsächlich
mehr menschlichkeit und mehr emotion
gewünscht und ich glaube damit macht man
sich auch als politiker glaubwürdiger
also er hätte sagen können natürlich
geht mir das navi nicht dort beschimpft
werde natürlich überlege ich mir wie
kann ich diese menschen einfangen wie
kann ich überhaupt mit denen in dialog
treten die wollen das überhaupt nicht da
sind momente die sind für mich echt hart
ich finde solche sätze kann man als
politiker durchaus mal sagen wenn man
sich dort hinstellen stellt und gespuckt
wird und bepöbelt wird wie viel
emotionen auch mal zeigen als mann und
dann auch noch als politiker versuchen
also du wünschst dir heute sicher fehler
mache
das ist genau nicht mein politiker
modell und dann ist sozusagen das
gegenteil und das ist gegen kaiser
nennen ich möchte ich wünsche mir
führungskräfte führungskräfte die ihre
verantwortung gerecht werden naja offen
zur schau getragene emotionen in der
politik habe ich immer im verdacht dass
sie sowieso gekünstelt sind insofern
fand ich spannend
ehrlich ich glaube es geht ihm nicht
wirklich nahe in wahrheit weil es
irgendwelche menschen sind die außerhalb
des diskussions spektrums sind ich mein
wenn jemand die minister gegenüber
schwule sau ruft disqualifizierte sich
so sehr dass ich auch vom minister
eigentlich gar nicht mehr verlangen
mitnehmen ein dialog gehen zu müssen
also es ist auch ein bisschen eine
showveranstaltung anders gesagt wer
schon wahlkampf würde ich sagen oder für
den wahlkampf kann es sich zwei oder
drei mal so eine truppe vor irgendwann
ministerium stellen raus kommen weil am
schluss hat patricia riekel die das
natürlich aus ihrer jahrzehntelangen
analyse von images von prominenten
perfekt analysieren kann recht ein
solcher debatten eine solche
auseinandersetzung wird immer 80 zu 20
für ihn ausgehen also ein riesen
pluspunkt ist bestellte werbekampagne
und nicht wirklich was schlimmes was da
passiert spannung
[Musik]
situation das war der ministerpräsident
aus sachsen kretschmer der in seinem
wahlkampf in sachsen super schwierig
gegen die ard die sehr stark war immer
wieder in diese protestgruppen
hineingegangen ist
da hat das bestimmt auch authentischer
sich heraus gemacht aber es hat eben für
ihn auch funktioniert er war dann am
ende derjenige der am meisten mit der
bevölkerung geredet hat und das
funktioniert wenn du dich als politik
mich also sehr wichtig da habe ich fast
ein bisschen schmunzeln müssen weil jens
spahn ein paar mal das hat er möchte so
gerne greifen das warum die menschen
sind aufgeregt sind und so wütend da
müssen wir jetzt nicht viel studiert
haben um das herauszufinden
weil die maßnahmen in ihr leben
eingreifen weil sie sowieso aus
verschiedensten gründen
nachvollziehbaren und nicht
nachvollziehbaren mit dieser regierung
durch sind und weil sparen in seiner um
den heißen brei reden rischen leicht
einserschüler strebe artigen
gesamterscheinung natürlich an sich
schon sozusagen er emotionen gegen ihn
freizusetzen imstande ist da muss man
nicht viel nicht viel wissen widerspruch
ist erlaubt hat er selbst gesagt das was
ihm da begegnet es war ja schon unter
der gürtellinie mehr als eher sachliche
widerstand woher kommt dass diese hass
und warum schlägt er gerade im so
entgegen fordern
das liegt ja nicht nur ihm entgegen der
der hass die ablehnung regierung skepsis
gibt gibt es überall gibt gerade eine
studie heute ist die rausgekommen von
der konrad-adenauer-stiftung dass 30
prozent der verschwörungstheorien
glauben das sind natürlich alles
potenziell die leute die auch da stehen
und dann auch dem gesundheitsminister
anschreiben weil sie nicht glauben was
da in der korona politik passiert dass
das eben basiert und korrekt ist also
insofern dass erwischt ihn als
gesundheitsminister das könnte die
kanzlerin genauso erwischen das könnte
ministerpräsidenten genauso erwischen
ich will das ganze ergänzen ich finde
lautstärke ich finde deutliche worte ich
finde manchmal keine gewählte
ausdrucksweise noch kein
ausschlusskriterium für debatten beim
viele menschen können sich gar nicht
anders äußern das meine ich jetzt nicht
arrogant sondern das ist sozusagen ihnen
nicht gegeben großer rhetoriker zu sein
und trotzdem muss der zorn und die wut
und die emotion er in den politischen
raum kommen aber wenn es beleidigend
wird oder wie in dem fall dann
homophob beleidigend dann finde ich gibt
es keine verpflichtung für den minister
der großen dialog zu führen sondern
sollte sich der oder diejenige wieder
hinlegen noch einmal über sich
nachdenken und dann im gesetzteren
worden die kritik vortragen
ich könnte jetzt gerne die
abschlussrunde einleiten du hast sie
vorweggenommen du hast es offenbar
geahnt was soll und laschet ist deiner
meinung nach ende des jahres oder wann
auch immer der parteitag der cdu
stattfindet der also neuer chef ich sage
nur laschet kann nehme ihn nicht als
selbstmörder und zwar auch im team mit
sparen
im team mit spannender klar kriegen was
sagst du ich fürchte und er betont
fürchte das wird also passieren dass
ständig klaus ausnahmsweise aber wen
würdest du dir lieber sind alternative
anzubieten ich glaube tatsächlich es
wird so kommen laut stadt wird dahin
marschieren wenn sich seine
umfrageergebnisse seine zustimmung seine
kompetenz werte nicht verbessern dann
glaube ich hat friedrich merz eine
chance ist am ende zu gewinnen und das
ist das risiko in dieser konstellation
frau rieke jetzt noch die chance auch
noch retten zu nennen
nein werde ich auf keinen fall ich
bleibe dabei das ist diese bestrebungen
der in der cdu gibt den sparkurs von zu
schicken und lasse das natürlich wird
sich selber kehlen das glaube ich auch
nicht aber man wird ihnen vielleicht
dazu sanft überreden das publikum
vorstellen und von jugend also haben wir
haben war sehr junge sehr junge
politiker ich denke dass man in
österreich also ich bin mit 40 jahren
ist sparen eigentlich im richtigen alter
um eine führungsrolle zu übernehmen dann
bedanke ich mich sagen zu schauen so
klar ist die cdu wählt ja quasi den
kanzler denn der cdu kandidat wird nach
aller regel bundeskanzler weil er hat
noch so eine partei so will das wird
eine ganz andere debatte aus
die wellen schlagen kann der abend das
gewissen zum ende kommen damit bedanke
ich mich für diese doch geäußert
separate runde vielen dank an euch hier
im studio und auch an frau riekel in
münchen liebe grüße das waren die
richtigen fragen sonntagabend und es
gibt auch nächste woche wie immer wieder
hier sonntag
[Musik]